we all good recording audio no we're not
good something's wrong with this go
ahead go and do the intro
good evening mouth breathers i am your
host for today
i am your host for today nosebreather
gantt and today are my fellow nose
breathers connor and joey
as you can see they love my intro right
now i actually did
that was like a me you dude
how can i make the most joey intro of
all time just like every convention of
intros throw that out
make some [ __ ] up yeah
so how you boys been good sweaty sweaty
it is still very hot we've talked about
summer already but it is still very hot
very moist um it's still very
it feels like a conversation my [ __ ]
dad i know right i'm just like yeah oh i
gotta i have to talk about the weather
before we jump into your comfort i mean
like oh as well yeah by the way you're
dying
but how is the weather
yeah this fast this feels
when you're british you just the first
thing you want to do is just talk about
the weather right or just complain about
the weather that's just part of british
culture yeah it's i don't know why it's
it's it's like everywhere
i feel like it's a test it's like are
are we going to socialize in the normal
capacity of the english standards we
talk about british weather first i'm
like okay i'm good i know what i can
talk about now or are we getting sued
yeah i get it because if they come at me
with something like way left field i'm
like all right you're right you're a
weirdo all right yeah i gotta think
about
it's like the only icebreaker that's
acceptable in british culture if if
they're saying you're having a nice day
i think i'm talking to a psychopath if
they just ask me how the weather is i'm
like okay i can i can engage in a
minimal conversation i guess that's a
left field like intro i thought we were
going like super like oh so the price of
gold recently is i think you've got it i
think you have to understand the the
sheer amount of skepticism that british
people have like asking how your day is
is like is it good and they're asking if
something's good
question you're british so inherently
it's not good so yeah
asking how someone's day was and
expecting any other response and oh it's
okay yeah is is you know and when i say
you start off talking about the weather
you never compliment the weather it
could be the best day ever and your
british people will find something wrong
with it you know oh it's a bit breezy
today in it and it's just like [ __ ]
25 degrees outside you know which is
very hot in british terms by the way and
now that i'm out there it's perfect
temperature
but uh yeah how have you what have you
guys been up to something's been on my
mind gentlemen i want to ask you because
i was thinking about this last night i
was turning over my bed wondering just
really oh jesus
i was like i was like do i have a weird
opinion on this or not so do you read
fan mail
no
honest answer honest answer no okay okay
you have to say it like that joke
those [ __ ] friends no no wait wait
let me rephrase that depends
okay
i don't want to sound like an [ __ ] no
no because like a lot of fan mail i get
is just sometimes you get really weird
fan mail and my my like we have geeks
plus for a reason right it's the filter
out of the like the
uh are you talking like physical family
are you talking like emails both
okay well i read physical letters
obviously yeah but like you have
physical letters well sometimes they do
yeah how do you get physical letters how
do they know where to send it to you i
don't know they just send it to geeksbot
oh god but like even like back you know
during like the convention days and
stuff like that like you know if it's
hand written right then of course i'm
gonna take the time to read it because
you know they put some time into it
anyone can write up an email in five
seconds right so it's like you know
emails it's different story if if it's
more than like two paragraphs then i'll
read it yeah just to see what's going on
you know i was thinking about this
because i i remember this whole thing
that happened a long time ago with this
youtuber i knew and it was this whole
stupid drama and uh you know one of the
points that this uh guy proud uh prided
himself on was the fact that he
responded to every single fan mail he
got
um
now when you hear that as a viewer
you're probably thinking that's amazing
one of the amazing guys that's great as
a youtuber when i hear that i'm like oh
he's a psychopath yeah right that guy's
bad news
that sounds so bad as a viewer i know
but this is like this is honestly one
that's honest to god it is like if
you're a youtuber you know that it
depends on how big he is right because
you reach a point as a youtuber where
you're like i'm gonna reply to every
comment and be thankful i'm gonna read
all the comments yeah which like
obviously we're thankful to our viewers
but you get past the point where it
becomes unmanageable yeah to like
respond to everyone yeah which is why
it's like the thing of you know i'm not
saying that oh you can't check them you
can check yeah right but like people who
are so proud about the fact they keep up
with so much of it it's like you know
you have to wonder you're like that
isn't healthy for anyone keeping up with
that amount of no well i mean let's to
be honest i mean most of it's praise
right yeah and i feel like when someone
is so into hearing about you know oh god
i love reading all these letters of
people thanking me i'm like yeah
you're just a massive narcissist
at the end of the day what you like
reading is you're like reading hundreds
and hundreds of letters of people saying
how amazing you are yeah well how much
they like your stuff and i'm like you
know it's like i guess you know
self-confidence aside right like it gets
to a point where it's like
even when i got like loads of physical
letters like there was only so many i
could read in a day before i got like i
felt like i was doing a disservice to
the letters by just reading them all in
a sequence because i'm like all right
now i'm now i'm doing what my human
brain does and just spotting patterns
and i'm spotting patterns between the
letters that i've yeah and i'm forming a
uh
number right yeah you do and i i don't
like the fact that it kind of ruins from
female for you that you read it i agree
with that yeah but i was having this
thought and i'm like i was i was
thinking about it and i'm like ah i
don't think i've ever seen youtubers who
are like i don't [ __ ] read any of my
fan mail i don't read any of my fan mail
or anything like that cause people are
scared to say it yeah but i guarantee 90
of the youtubers out there
don't read the fan mail i know it sounds
bad and this is one of those topics that
i love this is why i like trash taste
because we can talk about this right and
we can try kind of come at it from an
angle where can kind of explain it in a
way where it's like i hope that i don't
come off as the [ __ ] right because it
certainly sounds like it i mean i feel
like yeah no i get it like it's
definitely it's definitely a topic that
as a youtuber you're kind of scared to
talk because because you know a lot of
the people and i know this is so
anecdotal but you know i do see the the
line there and the connection there
where i i've me i've met a lot of
youtubers who uh you know they've a few
of them have fallen off now a few of
them still do it whatever but you know
they they prided themselves and they one
interacted with their fans and two uh
read all the fan mail and read all these
way interacted how so that okay that's a
whole nother thing yeah right yeah i i
don't trust youtubers who spend all
their day like in their discord
interacting with their community yeah
yeah right yes that's one of the biggest
red flags to me as a youtuber that i
don't because i don't really want i'm
just like how do you find the time to do
this because like you have to find the
time basically if if you're interacting
too much with your community and reading
families and stuff and then doing
youtube on top of that that to me says
you have no time to do anything else in
your life yeah i barely have enough time
to do anything else in my life yeah i
had to like cut this down a lot just to
make it manageable yeah because when i
when i had my discordance start yeah you
know it can be a very intoxicating
feeling to
feel like oh wow everyone's here for me
yeah look at all these people wanting to
talk to me i'm so popular i've never had
this before you know because you know
you you cut back a year or two before
this and i'm the guy who can you know
barely get four people to turn up to a
[ __ ] event yeah you know what i mean
like yeah so you kind of get intoxicated
on this like almost narcissistic
tendency of the fact that you love the
fact that everyone wants to talk to you
right yeah and that everyone wants to
come for you and again it's it's not i'm
not trying to slate the viewers or i'm
trying to it's completely different from
my discord
i'm a [ __ ] clown in my discord
this is the private verse but even then
okay yeah even though your your discord
is private right yeah
they they still want your time yeah
right and so that's a that's a really
difficult juggling act because you have
to separate yourself to a certain extent
to be able to you know have a healthy
relationship with it yeah because
you know i could talk about this forever
but like there's there's differences
audiences
i want to stick on one topic for now but
i will go into that because there's a
whole other thing between the difference
between male audiences and female
audiences yeah oh god yeah yeah yeah um
and they have totally different things
but yeah okay going back to the whole uh
discord and interacting and stuff so
yeah there's two kind of interacting
there's reading fan mail and all that
where to me reading the whole fan mail
thing is a very one-sided um
thank you thank you very much ashley a
one-sided my trash taste coffee
i'm trying to get in the middle of
something here god [ __ ] you 29.99
[Laughter]
you know
i i don't i just sat there and i thought
man it's so hard to bring up talking
about the fact that you don't read fan
mail
and not sound like wait wait what got
you onto this like thought process like
like did something happen because i was
just thinking back and i had like this
like uh this you know that moment of
realization you get in the movies yeah
and i've thought about this a lot um and
i just remember this this like i said i
remember the situation with this
youtuber uh who i had kind of a weird
interaction with i didn't really like
him i always thought it was quite
strange yeah
and one thing that uh he did that was
just bizarre is that he's one of those
youtubers who made like 500 parts of
opening fan mail yeah and on one part i
understand because i did this because
for a little while i felt guilty that
people were selling this stuff and they
weren't getting to see my reaction to
their stuff right but also once once i
got three episodes into doing this yeah
i realized
okay well there's only so many different
ways i can react to this these fan mail
yeah you know what i mean like there's
you know and some of these stories that
people would send you are so
deep and really intense you know and and
not to take away from any of them but
some of them would be really [ __ ]
deep yeah like and i think if they're
really especially feeling good to like
share that on video feels one it feels
weird to share that on camera and also
you know as a youtuber i'm thinking
when they wrote this story out you know
what did they want from me
what what did they what did they expect
when they wrote this story
what kind of response did they want and
also you know is it impractical for me
to
write back now occasionally i'm
saying this now i'm probably going to
never do this again because i
this is probably going to be because i
want people to take advantage of this
yeah occasionally when people did send
me like really uh touching things to my
email you know or very like emotional
things i would reply and just be like
hey man keep your head up or whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i would do
that because but i didn't want to
advertise that i was doing that because
i didn't want people to think that if
they sent me a sob story i would reply
being like hey champ pick yourself up
you know here's a 10 bucks [ __ ] off
what i mean but yeah you know you didn't
want to like sell yourself as like the
therapist right yeah no because you know
i when when you start doing the the fan
mail stuff more often than not i find
that it does come to that
um because that's just how it is you
know people realize you respond people
start taking advantage of that yeah
because i think like the biggest
difference between you and us
well at least me like when you were
basically building your audience is that
your contents a lot of it revolved
around fan interactions oh like 80
percent of it yeah i mean you had like
fan calls and fan mails and like reading
fan comments and everything like that
and to me i've like
like i don't know how many how much fan
mail you get i probably get a lot less
than what you had to go through so like
to me whenever i get a really deep story
or like a really long piece of email
like really long email um that's when i
do i'm able to sit down and read it
because i rarely really get one of those
most of the time it's just like can you
review uh school days please oh okay
message studio wit
that's the kind of meal i get most of
the time so i it's it's like i to me
it's like a it's like a nice break
whenever i can see someone who actually
has you know put effort into their fan
mail and that's that's to me like that's
why i always end up reading it yeah and
it does still like mean a lot to me that
hey i've done something for someone that
i've never met before yeah or probably
never me and that doesn't matter you
know
yeah i mean some of the [ __ ] just like i
got real [ __ ] up after a while because
i was just reading this [ __ ] for hours
on end like yeah it was just extremely
depressing you know because i want to
help everyone out there who's going
through [ __ ] like that but yeah you know
it's just some of the some of the stuff
i can't help everybody some of the stuff
is like i don't even know where to begin
like what do i even do to this you know
like i remember one time someone had
sent me a thing and it was this really
nice story about their dogs right and it
was just give me the [ __ ] thing
he couldn't see off camera but ashley
was just standing with the coffees like
that
like two minutes ago while i was just
like oh god it's connor's going to get
on like a really nice story right now
you know there was this uh there was a
story and i remember it was just so the
way they wrote it was like some kind of
memento s thing right where it was just
like i didn't know what was coming and
she talked about how you know these two
dogs were amazing and she's been doing a
lot better
and it was like it was genuinely like a
three-page letter and it was great it
was like all positive and it was like oh
yeah so i was doing really bad in life
and it was doing you know and these i
got these new support dogs that helped
me and it was amazing and then
at the end of this thing right of this
thing that's going amazingly she was
like oh and then my dogs died after they
got hit by a truck
and it was like this two thing of it was
like
and now it's not going so well but i'm
trying and i'm like what
what
what i was like emotionally like i was
like the biggest bungee jump it was it
was like some kind of monty python skit
you couldn't make this up it was so
if this was a comedy show you'd have
said the comedy was impeccably time yeah
this was so and i remember it because i
was just like what and i was like
the first time
and i you know it's always like you
can't help but laugh because you're like
this is so [ __ ] this is
so sorry i was like what is happening
sometimes you just have a moment you
like in life where you you don't know
how to react and you just your first gut
reaction just to laugh wow and it's just
like
i had to re-read it like three times i
couldn't believe it i was like wait what
i think it's just like a nervous like
reaction right
how do i react yeah you just i've never
had writing like that before yeah this
has been done in the book this should be
like award-winning this caught me
totally off i didn't even think it was
going there it was
not a sing there was no like hint there
was no indicator there like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was all
great and i was like what happened jesus
what is this yeah it's like it was like
someone it was almost like she
wrote in the letter like completely like
like three days and then like waited
like two weeks before she sent it and
then made like an addendum at the end
just being like oh and by the way it's
like a footnote there's been a ps
yes
it's not good now and i'm like
what and then this just also this is
just terrible i don't want to it's
horrible to deal with that stuff and
yeah it's it's like what what does that
person expect you to like react yeah and
so yeah exactly but you know not to take
anything over from her i do appreciate
uh her sharing that means obviously you
know that was something very very
emotional yeah yeah
and and in one hand i appreciate it but
also hand when i hear about people who
are reading tons and tons of these
letters and and they love it and it's
just like what like can you emotionally
handle all of this and if you can like i
have to like are you a psychopath yeah
like this is a lot you know it's like
imagine if you're a speed running
therapy for some people like this is
like you're just like you get the stop
story and you have to get to help like
they just they leave and it's like this
is horrible this is yeah i mean i mean i
think it's it's like unfortunate that we
we can't listen to everything because
like i got into youtube because i wanted
to like just find i want to connect
people i wanted to connect to people i
wanted to find people with the same
interests that i had yeah which is why
like a lot of the friends a lot of our
close friends in england that we had now
are like people i met through youtube or
through being fans of my content and
through that i i kind of like for the
for the longest time i kind of prided
myself of like you know if you're a fan
come say hi and maybe we can be friends
one day you know who knows and that was
that was when that was manageable right
and like some some of my first some of
my first fans are now like some of my
closest friends yeah one of them is
going to be like one of them every like
you know some of them are going to be
you know
at my wedding you know that's groupsman
right yeah yeah exactly so it's it's
it's gone from that to now like i cannot
you know even if i even if i'm sure
there are a lot of you guys watching out
there who i know i'm and probably you
know that we could be pretty close
friends we're just not gonna have the
opportunity for that unfortunately right
because most likely just because like to
me because there's one of you because
there's only one of me and there's
literally hundreds of thousands of you
guys and it's it's an unfortunate fact
that i just had to like make peace with
and just be like you know this this is
it's part of the job is managing
kind of like my fan interaction and just
interacting with the amount of people
you can
physically and humanly interact with and
get emotionally involved with yeah and i
guess and it's like that massive
difference between someone who has come
to that realization in their career and
is able to manage it and some people who
are just like nope if you're a fan of me
you're not just a fan you're a friend
you can approach me at any time kind of
thing but then they forget that the
larger they grow and the more and more
of those fans become friends quote
unquote yeah then it gets to the point
where they're just like that's just
their entire life right yeah yeah you
end up with people like what you were
saying that just yeah i mean that they
could have happened with their fans 24
7. that could have been me you know and
yeah there are a lot of youtubers out
there who have uh still do that still
who i'd say have uh you know at the cost
of their own channel yeah right
you know continue to do it because a lot
of them get really you know i
i've seen so many youtubers get so
sucked into their discord yeah um and
you know this is why i said it way way
back you know my number one piece of
advice is to not make a discord server a
public discord server which is why we
haven't made a trash taste discord
server yeah which even though people
have asked yeah it's the my number one
piece of advice to any youtuber because
it's it's a time sync you know managing
a discord server luckily now i i don't
manage it i've gotten out i don't i
don't go on there like yeah i mean i
post updates and
you know i people understand it now yeah
but you know i remember when i first
started stepping back from it i would
get a lot of messages being like i can't
believe you aren't active that's so
so wrong it's your discord so you should
be active it's like what do you want to
do do you want me to sit here and
message you so so the other two million
people can't have a video like yeah yeah
yeah you want to take time away just so
i can i can i can laugh at the meme you
sent me yeah like
[Music]
kitten lord xd you know what i was
trying to do i i actually had to coach
sydney through this because she actually
like had i think she had like a public
discord and you know at the beginning
everyone wants to interact with it's
great it's great it's great everyone
wants to interact with their fans as
much as they can and it got to the point
where cindy thought that
if she didn't do it then people would
think that she was ungrateful yeah for
for
you know the attention or for like for
them supporting her channel yeah i'm
just like and she grew to a point where
she was waking up just stressed she was
waking up and she was like i've just got
so many notifications yeah and not me me
too yeah and and it was like she woke up
and for a full like month i think she
was just depressed because she didn't
know how to handle
everyone trying to get a piece of her
attention i'm just like
look you've got to because because this
was this was back when like this is back
when she started to you know kind of get
a bit of a bit of momentum right and and
i like luckily she had me to like coach
her through it because i i just
literally had a go like a yeah because i
was just like look you've gotta just get
past this point where you just gotta
realize that it is part of the job and
part of the job is just understanding
that you can't give everyone attention i
know you want to i know it kills you to
show everyone how grateful you are for
their support and everything but it's
physically impossible for one person at
a at a certain size yeah like if someone
meets me in person and uh you know if
they want to speak to me i'll gladly
speak to you as you know
anything you we will talk yeah and i
would rather that so much more than a
message through the screen i don't know
it literally doesn't mean anything when
you're watching through it like discord
you don't know the person
i don't even know who you are like
they're just over here bro i don't know
what's going on honestly i think like
the best way to just have a casual
conversation is
it i mean you can't plan it which is
unfortunate but if
it's mostly conventions right yeah if
you see us at a party at a convention or
just like hang on we look like we're
just not heading somewhere or like busy
then we'll probably have time to like
have like a quick chat or something yeah
yeah that's what i want to do and the
quick chats are always the best yeah and
some and sometimes you meet an
interesting character and you're just
like yeah we should you should hang out
later you know at one of the parties
that we're going to or something like
yeah yeah i've had people i'm like yo
come on yeah yeah exactly right
yeah yeah but like you know
unfortunately that's just not something
you can plan you know we're gonna we're
obviously gonna find it creepy if
they're gonna be like okay so uh this
person's gonna be here at this
convention and he's gonna be here here
here here i can say hello here
and uh just like board it out
so we have to rendezvous right here
no because like i've had a really weird
kind of like strange
um evolution of like interactions now
that trash stasis started right because
obviously the world hasn't opened up yet
but i've now met like a few people
post trash taste that has just been like
so like we've met in like a normal
social situation so it's just been like
at a friend's party or like some kind of
gathering but uh they're like yeah i uh
i watch trash taste and the first thing
they say is like i i i know about the
parasocial relationship thing but like
i'll just say it up front and like i i
understand that there's like a
difference between
knowledge between what i know about you
and what you know about me and i'm just
like this is actually really weird
because i think that's the best way to
handle it just just like acknowledging
that yeah they're an active viewer and
they know more about me than i do about
yeah i'm just meeting that like i might
like you but i know you're not my friend
yeah yeah so i'm just like so i'm just
like cool let's close that gap then so
did you see the clip of felix talking
about it
he someone asked him like oh do you know
connor that uh he was like yeah dude
he's like yeah what's trash taste is
it's weird i feel like i know them but i
don't know them at all yeah
that coming from felix
like i feel weird i feel like they're my
friends but i've never spoken
i was like that's great yeah just saying
that yeah
that's the thing like if felix is saying
that then [ __ ] everyone is
susceptible to him
don't feel guilty don't feel guilty you
know the big boss man
yeah like the thing i'm trying to say is
we don't know how to handle it correctly
as much as you don't know how to handle
it we're all [ __ ] we're all [ __ ]
interesting it's a very strange
situation we've all found ourselves yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but like that's that's why i'm i'm also
glad that we are quite unquote like
famous on the internet
because like you know because like
that's that's why like if there's one
group of people who are [ __ ]
sociopaths it's [ __ ] paparazzi right
because if you've seen any interview or
just any documentary or any story
following paparazzi they're [ __ ] not
cases the [ __ ] anthony padilla video
like yeah that still blows my mind to
this day just like hearing just the
audacity of some of these guys just
being like yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
because if the opportunity is there i'll
take it because one [ __ ] yeah because
one thing i'm thankful for is that
because we've grown up in an age where i
think a lot of our viewers are more
aware of you know what it's like and you
know social boundaries and stuff like
that um because we have places like
trash talk about it but [ __ ]
celebrities back in the day they they
didn't have this you know they were they
were basically put on a pedestal and
kind of like almost looked at like a
commodity and you can do anything you
want to the celebrity you can break all
kind of social boundaries and it was
acceptable back in the day and that's
why paparazzis were able to do what the
whatever the [ __ ] they did right it was
just that like weird stigma of like oh
you are famous therefore you are open to
any criticism you are open to just
getting your entire private life exposed
by anyone at any time and you have no
right to say because that's the cost of
being famous yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
i remember one time i saw a clip of toby
maguire trying to like trying to just
just go out of his driveway and just go
wherever he wanted to the day and he
just got swarmed by paparazzi right
right and so
the paparazzi literally would just in
front of his car like trying to like
like a group of locusts right trying to
like snap this picture of toby maguire
and he like moves out slowly and he's
just like trying to politely say um
excuse me can you can you guys get out
of the way can you guys get out of the
way they don't get out of the way he
moves an inch and he goes uh excuse me
can i'm just trying to get out of my
driveway can uh you guys get out of my
driveway and they don't move and then he
of course like any human being he
[ __ ] gets angry and he loses it and
he goes
dude move out of the [ __ ] driveway
i'm just trying to get out
and then the paparazzi is like
wow
what an [ __ ] and i'm just like
how up your own ass do you need to be to
have this kind of mentality
the moment he started screaming all the
paparazzi just simultaneously started
drawing being like that's the story
right yeah yeah let's go which is why
this clip got posted up yeah
no one respects paparazzi anyway so it
doesn't doesn't [ __ ] matter no yeah
in terms of like the social hierarchy i
believe they're like below [ __ ] like
dung beetles man
like honestly zero respect for paparazzi
people would rather cockroaches in their
apartments
but yeah i i mean going back earlier to
the whole you know giving attention i
think uh
you know like i remember one thing that
people would say and they would like
they would praise you if you would if
you would interact with your viewers
they'd be like wow this is so refreshing
you know big youtubers don't talk to
their audience and at the time when you
when you have like 50k subs that
probably gets to your head you think
yeah i am i'm doing great like i'm why
can't these people interact with their
fans this is so fun this is great this
is going amazingly
and then you realize uh well you should
realize shortly after why that is a bad
idea because uh then you have no free
time like i remember specifically your
content starts to deplete well yeah i
remember i would spend like
at least two to three hours a day
on my discord like answering messages
keeping up with the server just doing
that and i'm like two to three hours a
day
on what like on what because the problem
is it slowly creeps up on you right yeah
at first it was like 15 minutes of your
day you just get 15 minutes
15 minutes where you feel happy you're
like oh people people like me people
like people like what i do that's great
and then like it's slowly like five
minutes gets added on like in a month
and then you do content for two years
and suddenly you're wasting two hours of
your days yeah two hours is just gone
and then you know also you know someone
gets banned from the server and if
you're active on the server uh you
definitely get uh the complaint for the
the reasoning you know one thing that i
noticed when i was on the server was
that every goddamn week someone would
come to you be like my friend unjustly
got banned
and this is connor's a [ __ ] yeah
he been my friend for no reason you
checked the log the guy said like the n
word like 10 times and he's like what
like what it's just words bro what do
you want it's just words is this how it
feels to be youtube
when they take down a video yeah yeah
like this is why i feel sorry for
youtube yeah it feels so nice uploads
like a titty and something like what do
you mean bro
i can't believe youtube what an [ __ ]
yeah
you know it's it's this
you know when the discord server starts
it's great and uh when you have to
actually moderate your discord server
that's where it gets held yeah
and then you know
you know when you bring on moderators
you know some sometimes i remember my
moderators sort of sometimes start like
infighting and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this what is this i'm just trying to i'm
just trying to make a server where i can
thank my fans and that now sent into a
whole uh you know uh house of
cards-esque situations
what the [ __ ] is going on
and uh there's just so many downsides to
it and um
i just it's such a it's such a complex
situation and um i feel like if you
haven't experienced it it's so hard to
think about all the possibilities of
stuff that comes up because i didn't
think about any other [ __ ] and even when
i was in the middle of it i didn't know
what what could go wrong
you know hey everyone it's me joey and
just joey the other boys are not here
but i'm here to tell you about the
sponsor for today's video expressvpn
internet service providers know every
single website you visit and isps can
sell this information to ad companies
and tech giants who then use your data
to target you you don't want to be
targeted i don't want you to be targeted
and that's why expressvpn is here baby
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so your online activity can't
be seen by anyone it's as easy as
closing the bathroom door you just fire
up the app and click one button and you
are fully protected plus expressvpn is
rated number one by cnet and techradar
and it works on phones laptops even
routers so everywhere you share your
wi-fi can be protected i use expressvpn
to watch anime on crunchyroll because
crunchyroll is blocked in japan i can't
believe that would do that to your boy
so you can secure your online activity
today by going to expressvpn.com
that's
expressvpn.com trash taste to get three
months of expressvpn for free back to
the episode do you guys still read
youtube comments
uh first day yeah yeah first day i kind
of i kind of want to get the consensus
of the feeling yeah uh from the viewers
yeah yeah um because i feel like the
people who watch on the first day of
your core audience yeah yeah and those
are the people i care about hearing
about the most you know i want to know
what my the people who watch my videos
day one think
um because you know when the video
starts doing really well and it goes
outside of your audience it's really
really weird comments yeah you know like
uh once that turned into not english
yeah so
like my rent-a-boyfriend video like blew
up i knew i knew it was gonna do well
because
it's very good clickbait like i mean you
see that yeah i saw that and i'm just
like this is this is going to be a bag
even if the video was me
even if the video was me just going like
a denny's and just like
texting a guy and saying i rented it i'm
sure the video would have done a million
views anyway just because the thumbnail
on the title is so good oh yeah um
and like i said i knew it would so
there's some of the comments i got on it
were just like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are these and it's like
ew is he gay
is men gay is it like
a man
it's like and just weird stuff like i
bet he smells nice and all that kind of
stuff and just you just start to get
like the really strange comments coming
out so i don't really give a [ __ ] about
them um yeah but yeah definitely day one
i i check sorry i don't know i want a
whole explanation no no no no no yeah
like yeah for me as well as like day one
is kind of like the consensus of like
again it's like it's the ones who
subscribe to you is the ones that's
always waiting for your videos so it's
like you know usually
i also don't just look at the top
comments either i always look at it from
no yeah
yeah you can't you can't always look at
the top comments because those are the
ones like if there's anything with
constructive criticism it's going to be
buried down somewhere yeah and i want to
those are the ones i want to find yeah
the most liked ones usually some kind of
meme that came out of the video which is
cool or quote from the video from the
video yeah i get it we all watch the
video yeah the problem is is that i
actually don't want to check the
comments half the time because i don't
want to check my youtube analytics
yeah that's me too i don't i i literally
click on the video i'm just like don't
don't show the views reviews go down to
the comments to check the comments on
the youtube app on the studio youtube
studio app uh the first thing that pops
up when you open this app is your views
how the video is doing
and the amount of money you're running
and all that stuff i don't want to see
that stuff daily and the elusive
something out of time we've talked about
i don't i don't want to know how my
video is doing every day
counterintuitively i probably should
care you know any expert in analytics
would tell you that you should be
checking it and studying it yeah i've
been doing youtube for like five years
off pure gut feeling and yeah i think
i'm doing all right i think i think i
understand what's going on yeah yeah
so i don't i don't want to look at that
um i don't care how much it's making i
don't i don't care how many views it's
getting i just i just want to read the
comments so i don't check it that often
because i have to see that [ __ ] yeah and
so i can't for me it's just like is it
monetized good i don't need to see
anything else
i'd say check every two to three days
now really once yeah yeah because like i
i think i check on the first day and
then that's just it like i just check is
this are people enjoying this video
that's that's all i need to know yeah
and then i just kind of leave it at that
but i remember before when i first
started you'd like there was a full
[ __ ] week right you i call it the
honeymoon period where you just you're
so proud of this video and you just like
kept refreshing the comments like and
you're just like come on there must be a
new comment there must be a new comment
and i like that like that that period
was like a full-on week for me before
when i when i released a video and then
the longer you do youtube the lower the
lower that honeymoon period is yeah
until like it's like it's different
because if you're really if i'm really
really proud of a video i'm still like
checking more comments than like some
other videos for example
and i was wondering like is it the same
for you guys or is it just like the same
for every video now
like how much how how much do you guys
see youtube as a job is it just like a
completely a job now
i mean i'd be lying if i said it it's
not it's no longer a hobby i mean oh no
it is no longer a whole it's no longer a
hobby
if it wasn't for
uh i think the job is what makes me have
to upload weekly yeah i wouldn't upload
weekly if it was on my own yeah yeah i
think i would do once a month
because i love like some videos i i
absolutely adore making like there's
this one video that uh has been in the
world i can't talk about it yet but it's
been in the works a lot of approvals a
lot of a lot of uh things have had to
have been done to get this video done
yeah but i'm hoping that when it comes
out it's gonna be amazing and it's it's
been like a passion project for a while
and that that's just like something that
i would have done yeah you know
regardless like if it didn't make any
money even if it wasn't my job like i
would have made that
like regardless yeah nothing and so
that's amazing when you get that but
that only comes around i feel like twice
a year at most yeah you get like a
challenge
truly passionate really amazing idea and
everything seems to be kind of working
yeah you know you get all the approvals
you want you get all the go-aheads you
get all the you know because you know
especially
now it's we we do a lot of filming
outside of our house
in japan you need a lot of approval
stuff it takes a long time yeah um
before it was just kind of like how many
hours can i put in on this thing yeah
now it's become the case of can i get
the right approval because sometimes you
just have to have a passion project that
was like i think that was me and like
the fake timeline i did because like how
when when did i first mention that yeah
it's like over a year ago yeah and it
just got released like a few weeks ago
oh yeah yeah because i'm just like was
that a passion project or a job sorry oh
that was a passion pokemon cause i'm
just like
i do really people
do people really want to hear someone
explain fate in 30 minutes
like
yes
but like i had so much fun filming that
and i'm just like this is just a fun
thing to work on yeah yeah i think i
think everyone enjoyed it except for the
fake community for some reason they saw
they got salty about it oh yeah i mean i
mean like you you gotta you gotta take
you gotta take with a grain of salt
sometimes uh being an anime youtuber you
can very much piss off a lot of
different anime fandoms
uh it's you know it's
it's to me it's part of the job right
because i i feel like you know i feel
like with you
you're more of like a personality with
like who sells himself on just you know
i'm a guy living in japan and i like
anime right whereas i think me and joey
have had our fair share of experiences
where because we maybe say our opinions
of an anime or maybe like we've gotten
to a point where we can have like an
effect on the community then sometimes
you know sometimes people can be unhappy
with what we say i don't know
unhappy is a it's a very loose i'm i'm
i'm being very civil with the words i
use right now i don't know i mean i'm
your i'm your guys's friend obviously so
i understand yeah you know where your
you guys are coming from and uh yeah
sometimes i feel like [ __ ] out man
this guy's been real harsh on you guys
i see some of these comments something
like jesus christ he just made a video
about fate chill out bro yeah chill out
why you have to be so messed up i mean
that's why that's like i'd be lying if i
said like that wasn't one of the big
reasons why i don't make videos on like
popular or big franchises anymore
because it's like it doesn't matter if
i'm praising the [ __ ] out of it it
doesn't matter if i'm saying an
unpopular opinion or whatever
the fanbase is gonna get pissed off
either way just purely because of the
fact that i made a video on it
yeah i think cause i never really i
don't know whenever i made videos about
stuff it was always like the kind of uh
bl communities and they're always just
really grateful that anyone was making
videos about that at all yeah
yeah it's weird right because like
because i've also like slightly stepped
into that when i made a video on killing
stalking yeah and that was one of the
most like praised by the community
videos i was like i thought i was going
to get shot hand to god bro bl fans are
like the best fans ever man they are so
supportive of anyone getting in the bl
in any capacity they don't really give a
[ __ ] if you get [ __ ] wrong they're just
like we're just glad that someone's
appreciating it yeah yeah because it's
so niche and some of it it's like
amazing work that just gets overlooked
because it's gay like yes i mean you
know so it's amazing and uh you know
seeing some of these communities you
know uh there are a lot of uh uh some
shonen communities they get very
defensive uh the facebook yes i remember
gone did this video uh i'll talk about
because god doesn't want to say anything
but i i i the people would be so harsh
to god they were like uh god made this
video about the fake timeline like oh
some things are wrong or oh how dare he
get you know make this video that's just
terrible and correct in so many ways i'm
like bro chill out man and i think some
of these were the smaller youtubers i
think they were getting like do you want
to make a video on it go ahead well i
think they have and they were just like
it's not as good as mine it's like
the point is you have to understand is
that you know if you're a fake youtuber
if you're a specific youtuber you're
going to be more focused on the oriented
details of it yeah when you're a more
general youtuber who covers more more
topics you know and you're covering a
wide span of things you're gonna be
focusing on entertainment yeah right and
i feel god's video in a lot of ways was
more entertaining when i watch god i'm
not i'm not i'm not getting out of [ __ ]
i'm not watching it for fake law i
couldn't give a [ __ ] i just want to
watch that i wanted to see law i would
go into the wiki yeah i want something i
want something just being real i want
something funny you know so when i saw
people when i saw people you know i feel
like i'm just defending my friend
keep going this is this is this is the
rare time where we
where we've like got each other back i
guess we've got your
you're missing the entire [ __ ] point
it's not to make a video that's correct
about faith it's a video that's
entertaining about faith the point is
that yes it's not going to be 100
correct if it is fantastic god's done a
great job researching the point is is
that yeah that might annoy you that some
details are wrong and that you've put in
all this hard work and your video is not
going to get as many views but by by
making a video about fate uh you're
giving an avenue for more people to get
into fate yeah right which you know the
when someone big makes a video about
something that you do it's great because
you get a kick down effect whether you
like it or not you get that effect yeah
you know there's the fate uh people who
made videos about it are gonna get views
from that video because guess what's
gonna be recommended on a fake video
yeah um and it was very i don't know
it's just another case of people just
wanting to take shots at the big guys i
don't know i've never really had to deal
with it so i
i'm all right but i feel bad for youtube
because for some reason you guys are
like punching bags for a little bit i
mean i don't know why i think it's weird
because
i i obviously never intended this but i
think it's just because we are seen as
kind of like pseudo critics or whatever
like i don't know like because i don't
see myself
as
anything of the sort i just see as
myself as like one guy giving an opinion
and i've that and i've said that so many
times in videos but the moment you say
that to the reviewing a critic fan base
they're like oh he's just trying to be a
critic he's just trying to be a review
he's trying to take out jobs and i'm
like no i'm really not i just want to
make a video on this because i'm
passionate about it yeah yeah i mean
like i think there's there's two things
especially in the anime community
because the anime community grew up from
being like a very niche small community
right so sometimes like sometimes i will
make a video or i will title my video in
a certain way because i do it with the
assumption that
the person watching it knows nothing
about the topic i'm talking about and
the thing is because anime fans were and
still are especially in niche
communities very very dedicated to
whatever niche or whatever fandom that
they are a fan of they get i wouldn't
say very defensive but at least like
they are very judgmental about any kind
of content that gets made especially
like i mean we talked about faith but
like especially shown in community oh
yeah i don't know what it is about
shonen community that is
they are just so competitive with one
another
like because there's so many of them as
well yeah
and age like you say you say an opinion
like it's just basically impossible to
have an opinion on any any singular
shonen show right i'm not
it's it's it's especially difficult
especially like if you just make a tweet
or something or if you say i'm enjoying
x more than x well people people or
people will like take those words and be
like what the [ __ ] did he just say no
[ __ ] i remember i tweeted out ages
ago saying like you know what after
all these different manga that i've read
from like all the popular stuff to like
the niche stuff no one thinks about at
the end of the day i'm always going to
go back to shonen jump yeah and the
shonen jump like community got on my ass
for it be like i can't believe you're
discrediting shonen champion and shonen
sunday and i'm like i literally praised
you guys
what do you want what more do you want
me to say but the thing the thing i've
noticed right is that this is for some
reason it's it's
for the most part only
only contained in like the shonen
community and the shonen culture yeah
like for example i listen i'm the isikai
guy right so let's say guys i prefer re
zero over no game no life nobody backs
an eye
no nobody bats knife yeah i say i prefer
demon slay over uh i say i prefer demon
slayer
[ __ ] sake i say i prefer demon slay
over
demon slayer demon slayer
controversial opinion
my brain's like don't say it don't say
it
i say i prefer my hero academia to
jiu-jitsu tyson everyone loses their
mind i don't by the way that that was
just that was just a that was just a
random quote that i just generated that
that's gonna turn the internet on fire
but of course someone's gonna take that
out of context and be like i can't
believe god said that yeah i think
there's nobody who respects my opinion
so
it's kind of no that's what i want i
don't i don't i don't want people with
trouble
my opinion whatever i say no one really
bets an eye they're like oh well i guess
yeah i've never had good opinions so
it's whatever but i want that at this
point like like i get it that you know
because i've never really criticized
shows i just kind of say i like it or i
don't i've never already gone and i
think it's when you've criticized church
people get there people start to
probably in some aspects value your
opinion
which you know
but at the same time it's like there are
some people there's a difference between
respecting and understanding an opinion
and taking that into consideration and
also basing your entire life around that
person's opinions yeah you know like i
even me like i've tried to
talking about
anime content i've tried to not be so
negative or like i've tried to like only
focus on things that i do like and i
that i want to highlight right because
it's a big difference
because i didn't used to be that way i
used to be like you know i used to like
clown on a lot of shows but now now i at
least try to
try to
just talk about things i like but even
even if i just make a quick joke about
something that then that one line from a
video that had nothing to do with
that topic or that fandom that
that you know that
one quote gets spread around on twitter
and spread around everywhere and
especially now that we stream and we're
on trash tasty
there are people that can just take one
line out of context from a conversation
that's not even to do with the anime i'm
talking about and just be like oh gantt
thinks this or god thinks that and i've
i guess it's just something i've had to
learn to deal with as
i could say the exact same things as you
and nobody will bat an eye but the way
you say it it's like bro shit's going
down it's like c don't be a certain
opinion it's pretty strange yeah it's
like
an opinion yeah i should always be
offended that nobody gives a [ __ ] what i
say but on the other hand i'm like great
if it means i don't have to deal with
this [ __ ]
god i wish i was you
well i think i think part of it just
comes to time as well because
unfortunately the longer you are on the
platform or the internet them the more
quote unquote like i hate calling them
haters because that just that just like
people who dislike you the more the more
people who dislike you will slowly build
up because i remember i i remember when
i first started my youtube channel and
like
i think like the first five years of
content most of the
opinions i saw of me were mostly
positive right but then there would be
one comments that you know had a
negative opinion of me or like one small
community and the longer you're on
youtube the more like the more
negativity that gets built up slowly
over time just because one your audience
is getting bit bigger and two a lot of
times when you get a hater or when you
get something someone who doesn't like
your content they're just gonna stay
that way and they're just not going to
give you the chance or another
opportunity yeah because they're not
going to watch your content anymore so
that one opinion they have you is going
to remain that way throughout the rest
of your youtube career right so i think
it's also a thing with time as well
because i think a lot of big youtubers
who've been on this platform for a long
time have had to deal with
negativity building up over time and i
think i think there's no one that
epitomizes this more than maybe felix
and i like i've never personally talked
to the guy but from what you've
said about
what he said to you and about how he
deals with it it's just like it just
seems like the most mature way it's just
it's just something you just got to deal
with right yeah honestly you just come
to part of the job do you find that it's
possibly a reflection of the content you
make you know when you're saying it's
more you're more negative focused
do you find that you tend to get a more
negative response from oh yeah
definitely when you have i mean that's
when you have a controversial opinion
then you all get controversial comments
as well right but like if you're always
saying like shows are trash or this is
bad
do you find that
or did you find that the viewers were
more likely to be negative about things
are you saying like are they more
positive now that you've swapped to
being more positive about shows yeah
definitely definitely like like one like
i i maybe that could be it for the
difference you know i mean like i i
because i
the reason i changed my content wasn't
because of only because of that is
because some of the content creators
that i used to watch and maybe i watched
back in the day like i kind of noticed
that man being being negative is just
not very fun and sure there are shows
that i don't get more views though it
gets more views because
and that's the tough part yeah so did
you like you know because i remember
there was always like um
like the the completionist whatever
right i don't know if you've seen his
channel no he always does like these top
tens at the end of the year top 10 worst
on top 10 best games right and he would
release them like back to back yeah and
always the top 10 worst would get more
views oh yeah all the time even though
they were like way lesser known titles
right people just want to know what the
worst thing is yeah i mean needle drop
does the same thing every year whereas
like the top 10 worst albums of the year
always did like twice the numbers of the
top 10 best yeah and if i mean i feel
like top 10 worst is just better
clickbait because nobody really wants to
know the top 10 best or like people are
less interested in knowing what the top
10 best is they want to know what the
trash is they know that's why i when uh
i try and be oh i try and dunk on
something i try and choose something
it's just unanimously no exactly right
which is why top 10 worst is good
because normally if it's like the worst
of the worst then then people there's
people won't bat an eye because it's
just like it's there to be clowned on
you know like i can clown on x-arm all i
want and people will [ __ ] love it
because it's hilarious yeah yeah i mean
have you seen exam you know i know you
have joe he's amazing
i love it
no it's great but like if you for
example have a controversial
opinion of a popular show or a popular
thing it's going to get a lot of views
but i feel like in the but at what cost
yeah in the in the long term like it
just it just
makes you seem like a cynical [ __ ]
and that just hates everything i'd like
even like even if you just make one
video about one popular show but just
[ __ ] on it people are going to remember
that for years
right i don't know why but people have
such long memories you could you could
you could just make like you could spend
five years is there an example that you
have in your head yeah one video though
people to this day still think i'm like
the guy who hates sword art online even
though i literally made what two videos
on it yeah out of the thousands of
videos i've made in my career
oh yeah yeah right i mean
even though even though there are so
many channels i can think of that i've
done
way more videos [ __ ] on sword online
and yet
i'm just known as the guy who's like oh
yeah you hate sword online right i'm
like
yeah but i'm also like all these other
things
did you really hate it online that much
would you play it out for the camera
look okay
i'll say it now i played it up for the
camera
yeah i know you [ __ ] for sure but i
thought that was pretty [ __ ] obvious
i made a vegeta review 69 video right
the [ __ ] parody character i made back
in the day right so it's like obviously
and again because back then when i was a
lot smaller and i was still building on
my channel but that's what you do when
you're when you're that's what you're
trying to do to grow you think you have
to be this exaggerated uh and you have
to hate everything right right i love it
so much because like i remember youtube
youtube like reviews i guess went
through this phase where being negative
was like the cool thing well just like
uh around when i i hate everything yeah
like i hate everything nostalgia critic
angry video game nerd where it's just
like andre yeah yeah exactly it's really
underrated it was just like being
cynical was like was just cool you know
that was that was a cool thing to do and
there was a dark period in two years of
youtube was it 2014 to 16 i wanted yeah
something like that yeah yeah then
people people i think the audience
because i i just felt like i just got
[ __ ] born of it because i'm just like
what what what's what's cool about being
angry i don't want to be i don't want to
be angry i want to be happy
you know
wow i want a controversial opportunity
right i just i just want to talk about
things i like i don't wanna i don't like
it got to the point where you just
watched you just watched content and you
could tell they were they were like
playing up the anger for the camera they
were like let's let's just nitpick and
just let's just find something that i'm
just
i can just like be angry about and make
jokes about even if i don't genuinely
feel it yeah yeah sort out online but
like i'm kidding i'm kidding well i mean
it was true and that's why i don't
really make those kinds of videos
anymore either because after a while i
just realized like there's only so much
you can do and say with that kind of
content after a while where it just
becomes like oh here's
his ex youtuber getting angry once again
about the hundredth thing that he hates
and so like all right cool
anything else you can offer to the to
the website no okay i'm just gonna stop
watching you you know like what are some
of the best fan bases in the anime
fandom that you think of because we've
talked about the trick question
three questions
they all are no
like i said i like the bl one
real fans seem so welcoming and i wish
more anime fandoms were like that yeah
i think as well like in a lot of senses
i think the the manga community but like
more so the the manga community that
delves more into like the more niche
titles yeah i feel is a lot more
welcoming because like now that a lot of
my content is a lot more in that
community i've realized that when you
mention a manga that no one else has
heard of but this one person knows that
they're like what holy [ __ ] they [ __ ]
mention my favorite manga yeah i want
more people to read this kind of you
know much like the bl community right so
it's like i feel it's again it's like
the the niche communities yeah i feel
like definitely the most welcoming the
nicest although i will say i think the
bl fandom they just don't like uh people
who like fujio bait yeah people who'd
like to try and like take advantage of
the whole gay uh thing who don't
actually give a [ __ ] about like
supporting anything like lgbtq well
obviously if you're just there there are
a lot of people and i swear on take talk
as well so many like people who try and
take advantage of stuff oh yeah
that's about it but i mean that's
justified i'd say um yeah no i i i
i yeah sorry we're in the massive
tangent then because yeah yeah yeah i
think we're talking about passion
project before yeah we're talking about
projects yeah to me like yeah going back
to the fate fandom it's really weird
because
being like being like okay i can't it's
so weird saying you're a fake fan right
because like
you say you're a fake fan and and
there's so many different levels of fake
fans it's like being a martial artist
it's like yo are you a first down black
belt fan or you oh this guy's a fifth
damn black belt fake fan holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you're all you're all losing
you're you're faithful that's right so
like you don't win at all so why it's
like the biggest loser it's it's really
weird seeing this dichotomy right
because a lot of a lot of fake fans have
always been very toxic and i i
i like i acknowledge that it is the
vocal minority but that vocal minority
is very very [ __ ] vocal right but
there's such a dichotomy between the
normal fate fans and then just the fake
go fans who are just like the most
welcoming people in the world and like
it's it's like they like because they
want you to they want you to spend money
yeah they feel so they feel less shame
like the fago fans they already know
they're degenerate they're just like you
know we got nothing to prove right and
then there's just like
like the
i would say like it's it's less fake
fans it's like fago fans and then
there's type moon fans right and it's
it's it's so weird like seeing their
toxicity evolve over time because i
remember back in the day when i was just
starting to be an anime fan and just
discovering fate as a whole right they
were being they were being toxic for
completely different reasons than they
than they i guess they are now right
because before
i remember there was there was like
going i'm talking about like old boomer
stuff now but i remember there was this
there was this review on a n that was
revealing fate zero right yeah and
apparently this guy this guy who who
wrote this review got so much hate that
he actually wrote like a blog post or an
article saying like oh
what like apparently i am watching
fate wrong like people are giving him
[ __ ] because he watched fate zero before
reading the visual novels or before like
or or before you've already got time for
that
yeah and i guess like now
i'm getting a lot of hate because to a
lot of hardcore type moon fans it makes
it seem like i'm making it harder to get
people into fate because i'm memeing it
up and like i'm like talk i'm memeing up
about how many series and how daunting
you're literally you come out you're
being like why why is he making it seem
complicated i'm like [ __ ] why because it
is called like and i'm just like okay
like as like as a fake fan i know that i
don't think it's that complicated but
you just like have some self-awareness
to like look at this chart or look at
this graph and just see how is this
going to look for the average person you
know that's that's like that's it's
it's
you can try to fight the good fight as
much as you want but at the end of the
day it's a daunting franchise to get
into yeah that's just that's just
something it's all perspective right
because again like to the fan to the
fade fan base it doesn't look
complicated because they've literally
spent years of their life
studying my definition of a complicated
show yeah if you need to
watch or research anything outside of
the the like the 25 episode run yeah
it's considered i consider it
complicated show if you have to then go
and do an additional video yeah that's
the other thing literally anything that
requires you to to go off the website
and look at something else to understand
the story is categorized in my head as a
complicated story but that's not
self-contained i can't just watch the
show and be like i understand
i have to look that's that's complicated
like i feel that's the majority yeah
yeah that's you know a lot of shows
don't require you to do that think about
every show you do not you know to
understand seven deadly sins you don't
need to [ __ ] go and read the wiki
article page to understand what's going
on you don't you know even jojo which
has a you know part six is a very odd
ending you know you can just start seven
you might be a little confused but you
kind of get what's happened yeah like
you know it's it's
inherently you can also enjoy the story
without fully understanding it so i mean
if there's any additional reading
information it's complicated flower i
don't give a [ __ ] what you think is
isn't as complicated if you have to read
something else it's complicated because
they haven't been able to fit it into
the goddamn run of the show yeah and
again like the whole definition of like
what a show is you know how complicated
a show is i feel it's just completely
dependent on the person right like you
know i feel you're speaking for the
majority yeah i feel like that's you you
have to think of yeah when you're a fake
fan clearly you have something that's
gone wrong where you can you can invest
this much time into something um yeah i
mean but a normal person will see that
and think that's absurd i'm not doing
that yeah yeah yeah i mean it's this is
like me as a fake fan commenting on what
i see as the of the fake community but
like
like how as as like the most hardcore
jojo fans how do you feel about the jojo
fandom well actually i was gonna say
like yeah say what you will about jojo
fans obnoxious 100 percent yeah but like
i don't i know many jojo fans i cosplay
all of them but who are extremely hyped
when anyone when anyone even gives a
shot on netflix or whatever you don't
give a [ __ ] if you read the manga it's
like dude just get into jojo yeah we'll
give a [ __ ] for any means necessary yeah
it's like i don't care if you have to
play the games i don't i don't care if
you have to
consume it through memes just get into
jojo i feel like that is like the num
like jojo fan that's all they care about
is get into it i don't care how you do
it
you don't skip parts yeah if you're
gonna just watch just once
netflix has this brilliant thing where
they play it in order yeah just do that
like you know i think that's it like i i
i could be wrong i do you i mean
okay well there's there's also this
thing
i don't know no no no i'm not gonna say
just skip parts i'm not i'm not gonna
[ __ ] do something sacrilegious but
like oh but like
there's there's there's a part of me
there it's just like sometimes i just
think
a series shouldn't get mainstream a
series shouldn't get popular you know
like there are some people who are just
like for example jojo right it's it's
popular as hell now right but like part
of me is just like i don't think jojo
should be a mainstream series because
it's just way too weird you know like
i'd like
like sure if you skip parts it might be
easier to get into but i just feel like
it's just not a series that lends itself
to being
like the [ __ ] marvel franchise you
know what i mean it's it's just it's
just too out there you know because i
feel like being part of the jojo fan and
like meeting a fellow jojo fan there's
like there's like it's like a connection
there you know yeah you also like that
weird thing i like yeah yeah yeah right
and i'm like especially
and especially especially
one of my favorite images and i don't
know why it makes me laugh
it's like the gif of the hulk running
in the desert and it's jojo fans they
see it unsucked
i don't know why
i you know and i love it it's so fun
it's just so funny
because
because jojoba music has just become
full circle where jojo fans just want to
clown on themselves
because it's i love it
there are just some captions there we're
going on another different tangent there
are just some captions that just stick
out to my mind for like some gif or
something that's that's one of them the
other one is just like that's why i love
this mainstream it's just so [ __ ]
weird it's just like that's why it is
mainstream so [ __ ] stupid i love it i
i think jojo just like i don't know why
how it was just so ahead of its time
because like it was made way too early
for me for meme culture but like it's
sort of like predicted meme culture not
even predicted it was just made for meme
culture oh yeah and i i like now it's
getting popular because of the memes
right and i feel like
you you meet a jojo fan and you're like
i know you went i know you got through
part one you're you're a real one you
stuck through you had faith man you
watched all 50 happy 48 episodes of part
3. you believed yeah yeah
i was bored in the middle too man i was
bored
together
i think i i think something that's not
often talked about jojo it's the [ __ ]
there's there's there is some boring
parts to it there is a lot of boring
parts to joshua i've met a lot of people
who have uh fell at part one and part
three like it is it is a hard show to
watch yeah
at times part three especially
i actually thought i actually put i
actually thought part one was easier to
get through than some of part three yeah
unfortunately you know i love part three
to death because it
brought us some of the most iconic parts
but you know as a jojo fan i recognize
that part three is especially the anime
is long yeah it is not good at times
yeah straight up it's i don't think some
some fights are entertaining as much as
i love the orangutan and then stuff like
that that was kind of boring like yeah
it ended really yeah it's just weird i i
think part three needed was like twice
as long as it needed to be
and like the ideas were less interesting
than what you saw in like other parts i
would say sorry disagree i don't care
that's just personally
that's because like with jojo fans are
like
that you you already hear about positive
things about jojo because jojo just want
more people to get into the jojo the
right way but uh
okay okay
totally off topic now uh kind of on
topic how do you guys feel about
gatekeeping then
okay being like shows yeah or just
gatekeeping fandoms in general because
i've become wiser with age yeah now i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah i don't really
give a [ __ ] when i was like
18 17. i probably cared a bit more i
definitely cared you know back when i
was making those like negative channels
but now i'm just like if you want to get
into a dude just like just get into it
and it's like because at the end of the
day you can get keep all you want but
like you know if people do come in and
find it and they don't end up liking it
yeah then it's then it's whatever like
it's not that's not gonna make a
difference for you i mean
it's easier for me to say now you know
my wallet is dependent on people getting
into anime you know
people get an anime i'm like come on in
come watch some videos about it you know
what i mean
i'm like come up you want to find more
about uh some some blah blah blah dude
come on i got the right stuff i'm right
in bro you know when you you know when
you when you uh you get some uh
you want some medication you want some
additional shots you come to me you know
yeah you know and now now it's great
because you know
odds are that if you watch anime you
might get into us so i feel like it's
way easier for us to be like yeah dude i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah come come watch i
mean but i feel again it's as you said
it's because we have you know matured a
lot yeah but also yeah like i just
realized like oh it's kind of pointless
at the end of the day but looking back
when i was 16 17 15 you know i think at
the time i was probably defensive of it
because i was
i i was probably this is probably all i
had yeah you know that made me happy
yeah you know yeah when you're when
you're 15 60 you don't really have much
to get happy about yeah yeah and uh to
me it was probably a thing of i don't
want someone
these normies getting into it because
there's something that i care so much
about and i know i'm so i'm the only one
that understands this
yeah you mean about it but i also you
know i feel for people who who tie a lot
of their self-worth to these shows yeah
yeah and i try and you know when i do
talk about these shows as much as i want
uh to to not discredit them for caring
about it i i want to kind of do them
justice but also help help understand
that people coming into their show is
not affecting them enjoying the show no
yeah because because i think the thing
about gatekeeping gatekeeping is that i
understand the mentality of why people
want to gatekeep and why people do it
you know i understand it and in even
some ways i do even empathize with it i
just like i i think i've just like grown
past it because
um because like i remember like back in
the day when you're an anime fan you met
another anime fan and there was just
like those
that was like just this [ __ ]
connection right away yeah you
talk about sucking dick
we just skip straight to [ __ ] pants
right now anal sex man
no just no just [ __ ] no
it's like bite down on the pillow
you know that like [ __ ] sonic and
mario gif
that's better
anime fans when they met each other in
the early 2000's that's what it was like
man you know especially in like
the uk where you don't really have many
avenues to meet anime fans yeah it was
insane like it was like you immediately
became friends yeah yeah and then like
there were there was like so much that
you had in common with each other
because you you just had never met
another person that was just that just
watched anime or even knew of it so it
was there was just like this it's gonna
sound so cheesy but it was just like it
was just like a special bonds that you
had with you that you had that like just
everyone outside just didn't have and
then like slowly as anime got more and
more and more popular it just started
feeling
less special i guess and you know that
sounds really pretentious but
you know it it it was special to you
because it felt it felt like something
that only you had or only a small group
of people that you could connect with
had and then as that medium grew you
found more and more people that maybe
you didn't vibe with as much or you
didn't connect with as much and you're
just like well this just isn't as
special anymore and i feel like most
recently the community that's felt this
the most probably is the [ __ ] v
tubing community because my god the
amount of gatekeeping i've seen in the
v-chipping community is like [ __ ]
insane when it started to blow up last
year oh you're a youtuber fan name every
veto yeah i remember when you know i
feel like there's been like waves like
so i feel like first gen anime fans
people who had to somehow bootleg it
from japan on a vhs tape and then second
gen is probably your gen where you were
able to get some online but it was
mainly through dvds and sharing yeah
yeah yeah but you were able to download
self yeah and i feel like i was like
next-gen like this is where like my
first experience was like espanol sub
part one
that was like that was like the worst
option for me yeah yeah and i
i feel like
yeah we were definitely seeing that with
v tubers now
and it does make it more like less
special but i feel that oh i forgot what
i was going to [ __ ] say man i had a
point that i totally forgot oh my god
i'm [ __ ] i mean i was i was gonna say
that what the anime community went
through is basically what the gaming
community went through 30 years ago
right like you know you start looking
back in the 80s there were kids who were
like oh you play [ __ ] video games you
[ __ ] weirdo but then when you find
that one person who's like
you like sonic 2. i like sonic as well
oh my god and that's what you know and
then they kiss right
like
and
but you know and then you know like in
the 90s and like early 2000s when gaming
got more and more popular and then you
know the school bully would also be like
yeah i played video games as well did
you know that
and uh and then you know you would just
yeah and then at that point it would be
like oh maybe this isn't like a special
thing anymore because now everybody is
doing it but then at the same time
that's like a good thing because now
we've got so many more games and so many
more amazing games that are just like
openly talked about with everybody so
like yeah at the end of the day you know
all those people who are gatekeeping
like video games and stuff like that
didn't really get anything out of it if
anything that was stopping the
advancement of something i mean i i i
like the thing with the things that you
know i understand having things feel
less special but at the end of the day
you've got to realize that
to like kind of claim this kind of piece
of media or kind of fandom thing as
yours it's just selfish at the end of
the day they don't make it for you they
don't give a [ __ ] about you yeah they
make the show because they want to make
money they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
exactly right why are you having some
connection to this i get it you love the
thing and you know and yeah there is
some artistry behind it and whatnot but
yeah at the end of the day it's like
you're not [ __ ] special and the show
doesn't belong to you yeah and so i feel
like it's almost ignorant to believe
that you have some ownership over it
because you you cared you know like yeah
you know even as youtubers you know you
you do see people like i was here first
and as a youtuber i'm thinking i i don't
care who was first
it's great
i appreciate it and i appreciate people
have been watching me but at the end of
the day it's like i don't think you're
any more important than someone who just
came in you know the only difference is
that you were just at the on the youtube
algorithm at the right time the like the
right place you know no one searched for
no one typed in sea dog va you know what
i mean yeah yeah
so it's you know i i to claim some
ownership over there it's like you they
found you in the same way that the
person who subscribed to you yesterday
found you yeah you know and i don't and
i'm sure the people who made x anime or
made x movie feel the same way where
it's like i don't i don't care how you
found us as long as you're watching
you're just talking about a site then
sorry my my
you're like x anime i was like
i was like
like ex videos
i can't hear the word x on the word and
not just think the whole the trash
they've said is falling apart as we
speak
do we want to take a break yeah let's
let's take a break while we
fix the set this episode is sponsored by
mac weldon you're a busy guy so stop
thinking about what to wear and just
embrace the radically efficient mac
wilden daily wear system the daily wear
system is a selection of clothes rooted
in smart design made with performance
fabrics and built to work together from
breathable t-shirts and polos to stylish
button ups and shorts underwear and
beyond mac wilden makes it easy for you
to dress for work leisure and play or
wherever the summer takes you god you're
just basically speed running life at
this point
god talk about optimization i am
currently wearing my mac welding
look at that is it comfy you bet your
answer is it how's it in the summer oh
you bet it's it's breathable it's firm
it's the right amount of underwearness i
don't know how to describe underwear
it's amazing the underwear is perfect
for any day and i love that i don't have
to think about it any summer any winter
you name it i can wear this underwear no
problem for the ultimate lacy sunday
their ace switch shorts have modern
tailoring and pair perfectly with their
ultra soft ultra upgraded pima teeth
sounds sexy and for weekend travel both
near and far their silver knit polo and
radius shorts are perfect high tech
highly packable combo highly packable
combo
it is so what are you waiting for buy
some time this summer with the mac
wealth and daily wear system for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
trash taste and there's a promo code
trash taste that's macweldon.com taste
promo code trashtaste for 20 off mack
weldon radically efficient wardrobing
back to the episode i mean at the end of
the day god it's hard to sit here and be
like gatekeeping good
do it
it's like it's it's i i feel like it's
such a dated argument and and us being
like hey guys gatekeeping bad it's like
[ __ ] gatekeeping has ended wow
wow yo gatekeeping being real silence
since they dropped the episode of trash
chase man that's all i'm saying
and delve into it but at the end of the
day it's quite hard to just be like yeah
gatekeeping good
when is gay keeping ever worked out to
literally never yeah if things if things
get popular things just get popular i'm
sorry that's just that's just the
end-all be-all and it's gonna get if it
gets popular then unfortunately we have
no control over it so yeah
i don't think a single fan has any
control over how popular a show is going
to get especially when they didn't make
it yeah it's like the only thing that
can kill a creation is the creator you
know at the end of it even then you know
even like you know is that like
conspiracy theorists gatekeepers what do
you mean people are like believing like
conspir conspiracy theories do they like
gatekeep like
like
oh oh yeah i think the moonlighting was
fake
how fake tommy tell me about it you know
oh you're just a fake one you saw on the
news bro
oh you're a conspiracy
they like everything like do they like
keep the intensity of the theory i
remember when the anime fandom went
through a phase with like it was like a
genuine discussion about how to spot a
fake anime fan
like do you remember this joey you you
must remember this joke yeah he
remembers this i made a video about it
i think it's like i think it was like
the third or fourth video i ever made
was called like how to spot a fake
target
oh my god what a throwback
wow i'm
oh my god
and i remember thinking like damn i just
made some biting commentary
how did you
it was like eight years ago but i feel
like joey was that stereotypical
stealing gatekeeping anime
i'm not even gonna pretend that i wasn't
that guy because i was absolutely that
guy but then again i think a lot of
attitudes were back then and i feel it
was again it was those kinds of
antitubers who i i feel like
you've uh
you've read the room pretty well as
time's gone on like i feel like you've
understood
what to change yeah well you know i
became an adult
at the end of the day i realized oh all
this [ __ ] about like gatekeeping and you
know hating on a show that's popular you
know to pose a controversial opinion
that's just childish it's a lot of
energy man to get angry about this stuff
so i just you know i i i'm sure i would
gatekeep if i had the energy for it you
know what i mean yeah
and you know me in real life i'm like
the least angry person
yeah i don't get angry about it i feel
like i get angry about dumb [ __ ] in life
i don't really get angry about stuff
like i get angry about like oh my my
taxi is two minutes late i get like fake
angry over it i just want to get angry
about stuff but i'm not actually angry
about stuff i just want to make i just
want to like
to get angry about saying to god i'd be
like this pissed me off i'm not actually
pissed off but you're just saying i just
want to say i'm i don't know why i like
doing that i think it's just part of
being british yeah i think
yeah and everyone will know that i'm not
actually angry but it just i just don't
know why i like getting worked up and
like a funny i know when you're actually
angry because you don't tell me you're
angry
i think i actually get angry i'm like
silence
oh he's actually angry but like i never
get angry about stuff i i like or
anything like that because i'm just like
oh all right okay uh yeah i mean okay
cool yeah it's it's to me to me it's
like if i get angry over someone's
opinion or something like that which is
why like would you like i [ __ ] love
trash taste where i'm just like you you
have a [ __ ] opinion about food or music
or gaming or whatever i'm we can just be
fake angry and that's why i love
discussing it because i love discussing
with anyone right because you can like
when when i call someone when i say
something that's trash taste
trust is fake
angry when i say someone has trash taste
you can say with the knowledge that you
don't actually mean it you know and and
if someone actually takes that seriously
then i can be like good i think i get
angry but the emotion isn't there yeah
actually some of some opinions you've
said i'm like what the [ __ ] i'm actually
pissed off but like i'm not actually
like upset yeah but you're not going to
be like after the camera turns off
you're not going to give a [ __ ] you get
a visceral reaction where i'm just like
um i need to say something right now
right well the fact that you just don't
like the bidet thing i actually may be
like kind of angry yeah i'm just like
imagine like you know getting the
standards i've been all here
like you've had this amazing opportunity
to have your ass sprayed and it just
pissed me off that you didn't want it
anyway that's a totally different
argument um yeah i mean uh these are
flashing oh yeah should we stop what the
[ __ ] is going on here i'm angry
being fake angry
this is what it is
just be angry
i can't remember what point it is i
don't know
i don't know
our cameras cut out uh they ran out
there the sd cards were full so yeah
yeah we lost the point that we're on
basically when i'm angry i'm not angry
when i'm angry
when i'm angry i'm actually angry yeah
well like going back to uh because i
like going back to
like
having haters that won't give your
content another chance
have you ever like
watched someone's content said it wasn't
for you and then for some reason you
came back years later and you're just
like damn okay this content's actually
pretty good
oh yeah i've had a few options like a
few times where i've been like that but
i think it's also because like
you know as you grow older the type of
content you watch is just gonna be
different right yeah yeah so you know
i've had the opposite effect as well
where it's like you know i think it's
very common to be like oh i used to
watch this youtuber i grew up and then
oh it's not so much for me anymore so
you can grow out of it but i think like
growing into a channel as well is very
much i think i think that's more
interesting because like you grow out
you go out of a lot of channels you know
a lot of a lot of content becomes dated
you know especially if the creator
doesn't evolve but what i find more
interesting is that if you find a
creator that you just think is not for
you and then you come back years later
and you're just like damn you're you're
actually a cool guy you make cool
content oh like you know if like 10
years ago right when i was in my teens
you would never catch me watching like a
tom scott video or or a marc rober video
right but like now i [ __ ] love those
channels because it's like super
interesting and i feel now that i have
so much more of just you know a base
knowledge yeah to be able to appreciate
content like that yeah yeah whereas you
know again 10 years ago i'd be like give
me the poo poo pee pee jokes
those don't exist on this channel boring
yeah i'm trying to think if there is any
youtuber i i feel like the biggest
example for me was probably felix where
like especially when he like debuted as
like the let's play and
the face of youtube yeah i'm just like
i'm just like who is this guy
who is this guy like making like you
know i think he was like screaming
everything streaming every video like
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] doing ear rapes
like every every five seconds or
whatever
and i was like this is just not my kind
of content and then like it it's so it
was so interesting seeing his content
evolve over time and just being like
okay he's not he's not even close to the
face of youtube anymore
at least officially yeah and um and now
like to me he like makes content that
was just like
i i just started watching him like years
back like after he had stopped the let's
play phase because i i can't remember
how long it took for him to to like
change his content for being like the
let's play a guy to just being like the
i'm just i'm just a mean guy and i'm
just gonna do what i want because that
that content appealed to me way more and
it was just really interesting to be
like oh he's a way cooler guy than i
ever thought he was when i was a kid and
i thought and i thought this was the
kind of content that he made yeah
definitely i feel like during his let's
play era like you know he was showing a
lot of himself you know because at the
end of the day like i think the best way
for let's plays to go is to have that
personality that you can you know yeah
kind of attach to but at the same time
like now that i know him personally i'm
like that wasn't you like that that was
not feelings yeah yeah i feel like you
become a successful youtuber when you
stop trying to be a youtuber yeah yeah i
think the
real goal to being a good youtuber is to
stop trying to be one yeah yeah yeah
yeah like when you just embrace just
yourself
yeah uh like he he makes videos on like
philosophy from time to time yeah yeah
yeah you know even though i might not
particularly have an interest in that i
think there is something uh that is very
interesting about someone who just wants
to talk about something they like yeah
uh and once you have that basic
understanding of how to make a video
entertaining you can then apply that to
things that people your audience
probably didn't know anything about yeah
and kind of get them interested in it or
at least have them entertained for four
or five minutes yeah i mean my favorite
video from him to this day is still the
one that it came completely out of left
field that he made a couple of years ago
he just made this five minute video of
him
spilling his love of a blam bam that was
that's oh my god that's my favorite
phoenix video as well because it was so
just like it was nothing like he had
ever made before like yeah i mean he
made you know anime content every now
and then yeah yeah yeah but for him to
like he wasn't even on camera it was
just his voice
and just pictures of panels and him just
it's spilling his love over this very
very niche yet amazing manga series and
i'm like damn dude like that's the most
human i've ever heard you being honestly
like a little secret here but that video
actually inspired me to do more personal
videos as well it was it was that single
video that just came out left field i
was like yo what what pewdiepie is this
yeah i like like like like
yeah yeah i know right i know right
because i i think it was it was that
video not only like got me back into his
content but also inspired me and
inspired me to change my own content to
just be like maybe i don't need to be
always be the haha funny guy maybe i can
make serious content as well right yeah
yeah funny guy
i don't like i think the biggest
curveball i've like had recently was
recently i like got recommended a video
of logan paul's editor right right who
went through his
uh who basically broke down how he
edited some of logan paul's newest
videos so it was like it was like a new
i i believe it's a new editor that has
just been around for the more recent
content and he broke down what he did
during the editing phase and like how he
broke down the story and narrative and
how he made certain jokes work and i was
just like yo this is he this guy knows
what he's doing holy [ __ ] he's a really
good editor and then i watch some of his
more recent content and obviously like
separating the man from the content he
makes it was just really good content i
was like i was like [ __ ] blown away
that i was enjoying a logan paul video
and i just genuinely thought it was like
good content like i don't know he
doesn't upload that often
anymore because why would he when he's
making [ __ ] millions of dollars
boxing whoever the [ __ ] he's going to
box but i want to box someone so bad
just just for the money i don't even
give a [ __ ] about the sport
so much money they're making yeah
no but i agree though like you know
again like there was always for the
longest time there was always that
stigma of you know like oh logan paul
video equals bad right but again like i
feel logan paul's one of those people
who you know to his credit has kind of
done a 180 on his content and has really
like showed that like oh someone can
actually kind of mature and like make a
better person of themselves and you know
like you might not be exactly a fan of
him but you have to respect the fact
that he has changed his content yeah in
a lot of cases and for a lot of people
for the better yeah you know and this is
just me like purely as a content creator
appreciating when someone makes good
content you can tell when someone's
making good content and i can at least
appreciate that you know what you do off
the camera something completely [ __ ]
different you know um but yeah i mean
like going back to the boxing thing
is there anyone you want to box sorry
you you
you just mentioned that and i was just
like i i need to know yeah now i need to
know anyone who uh i should make a t
list of youtubers
youtubers i can beat in a fight
boxing
someone who
can help me get a lot of money from it
that would be good that's
dude why would anyone else do it what
the [ __ ] no yeah they're all doing it
for the money i i'll do it for the money
the money seems crazy the money's like
the money is actually insane but like
okay like one one thing one thing that
i'm always like struggling with as a
creator right is is the kind of like the
the upload schedule that you gave
yourself right because like to me i've
you know sick unfortunately success
i mean like for me it's like way less
than you guys right but like like you
see a lot of youtubers go for this phase
right where they have they have like
this very strict upload schedule and
then they get successful doing something
else on their youtube and then their
uploads you kind of notice that the
upload schedule for their main channel
or their own channel you get successful
doing something outside of their own
channel yeah yeah like are you ever like
how much personal attachment do you have
to your own channel that would you ever
be scared if it like if it dies even
though you're doing well outside of it i
mean we have trash taste now which is uh
yeah i mean obviously i don't like
failing in anything i'm i'm a
competitive guy i want to win in every
aspect of my life i want to fail in
something you know
okay if you if your youtube channel dies
are you a successful youtuber
well i mean
okay if your youtube channel dies but it
was once successful uh were you are you
a successful youtube channel well it
depends like there's plenty of people
who you say you're a failed youtuber
there's there's kind of people who are
still succeeding on like other platforms
it depends how your channel died yeah
you know like if if you if if you killed
it with your own volition and like
because of something you did yeah then
like you know maybe oh yeah but i don't
i don't buy the whole thing yeah the
algorithm [ __ ] me a [ __ ] off
not like that if it's like if it's like
you know if someone just said like if
you're a really successful youtuber and
one day you're just like you know what i
kind of want to do something else and
then just like peace out then i think
you can say you're a successful youtuber
if you got canceled for some [ __ ] maybe
not if you had like a slow decline your
videos weren't really improving you'd be
kind of stagnated you know your channel
kind of fizzled out um
i don't think in in that case that
you're a failed youtuber everyone not
every everyone will peak eventually you
know that's just that's just a part of
life and that's just part of the
platform it's just a matter of like when
you think it's the right time to end it
you know like yeah because some people
or some people don't even end it but
they are you know they're still living
pretty comfortably and they're still
getting decent enough views on what they
do it's just not nearly the same level
as what they were doing what's your
definition of a successful youtube
what's success to you connor
money
because there's so many youtubers now
then i'm just like whatever happened to
them look i mean it's
you know it's one of those things where
let's it's very hard to tell someone to
do the exact same thing they're doing
for
half the money yeah you know it's it's
just mentally it's it's a hard thing to
do yeah regardless of how good the money
still is or how you know it's very
difficult to tell someone hey just
accept you're doing half as good as you
were last month yeah you know what i
mean because that's something that takes
a toll on you because you know you you
know you're capable of getting
what you had yeah and yet how do you
you know because especially if it's like
more than just one person if there's a
team of you it's impossible to get the
team everyone on the team to be like
yeah dude let's just keep doing what
we're doing for half the money yeah you
know
it's the top that's it's just the
reality of it yeah do the same thing for
half the paycheck you know because stuff
like uh
god i don't know like uh yogscast or
whatever when they were making like i
don't know [ __ ] a billion dollars or
something from minecraft yeah or game
grumps yeah how do you how do you
convince the gang to stay together
when the money is going as well is this
this sounds like a [ __ ] prelude for
trash
just like things that have aged horribly
yeah just just see this clip getting
posted in like three years or something
man i mean you know i feel like in terms
of that you know uh
i feel like it depends on what you are
doing like if you if you have an insane
schedule
it's the the likelihood is gonna be
there where you're gonna be more likely
to quit if the money isn't as good if
the schedule is intense you know trash
takes me just 10 hours so we can [ __ ]
talk
i can't see uh anytime soon where this
becomes a burden to my life no no oh
[ __ ] i gotta talk once a week you've got
to go right talk to my best mate oh my
god you know is it worth my throat power
i don't know i don't know you know i'm
just trying to say that just in case
people get [ __ ] boring so like oh
she's like what they're mentioning
groups declining
and you know i i well again like okay so
then taking that same you know like
hypothetical that you were saying like
let's put that in the case with trash
trash tastes right right so like would
you go with half the views would you say
that in like you know i wouldn't however
many years time if we were getting half
or a quarter of the views right yeah i
just want to talk i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know we i wasn't expecting a
million views anyway no i don't i don't
care if you know how
i was prepared for like we we
were prepared for 100k after a year
we've said this many times
at the end of the day this is and it
always has been a passion project and i
just want to talk yeah i've got a big
mouth i i wanna
i wanna just talk with my friends you
know and i wanna have an outlet to do
that um whether that's narcissistic you
can judge for yourself i don't know i
don't know what it is i don't know if i
need to see a psychiatrist about it i
don't know but um
yeah uh it's just that was what it was
for me it was never a it was never a
business venture it was always we never
planned for this to be like as
successful as i mean obviously more
success obviously if we can make good
money we'll make good money and we'll do
what we can but obviously if it stops
making money i'm not gonna care um but
because i have i have other things that
i'm doing and it's i never try and put
all my eggs in one basket but you know
in cases where there were channels where
people's whole career was riding on it
it's hard to i find it is hard to
convince people to stay on board when
the money is like one third one half you
know it's it's it's hard well i think in
that case it does like you do have to
kind of follow your passion right follow
because you're not going to be happy
grinding out the same same content that
you've been making that really shows if
you are passionate as well if yeah if it
does if it does plummet yeah for some
reason but also again there has to be a
question that has to be a question has
been answered there is like okay if the
views did half
something has gone wrong whether you
like to admit it or not something has
gone wrong and it's not always the
algorithm sometimes okay on the freak
accident you know with the whole uh okay
okay i'm back to young's cat it doesn't
even [ __ ] know you're successful what
happened to you so your channel made uh
uh minecraft videos and they didn't
really
you know you could blame them
you could blame the algorithm and yeah
there was a time when the algorithm was
changing but if one thing has been
proven minecraft has been everlasting on
youtube yeah and clearly what's needed
to be done was to change the content
yeah right and they didn't change the
content so
you know time and time again
youtube has proven that it is more often
than not not youtube's fault yeah yes if
you're an animator you've been [ __ ]
over yeah but also
animation channels are still doing well
so you have to change what you're doing
i mean there's there's animation
channels that have done well because
they've
adapted their kind of work
you know everyone wants to demonize
youtube and they they change the
algorithm and it is what it is you know
at the end of the day
you as youtubers you're on borrowed time
yeah it's always changing
you should have known better when you
were getting into this it was always
changing yeah you you you are you are
building a foundation on quicksand you
should have been changing that
foundation as you're building this tower
constantly and and so when i get angry
when i see these youtubers who complain
about their youtube video being
demonetized on twitter they they throw
it fast that it's not being it's not
getting the same views and i want to
reply to them but we're mutuals and
we're supposed to be civil and i wanna i
wanna just slap them and be like listen
you know what's going on don't don't try
and get your your fans to shout at
youtube they get enough [ __ ] yeah and
there are youtubers uh i won't name them
but there's a lot of them who still do
it who constantly complain at youtube
but it pisses me off because i'm like
this is not youtube's fault this is your
fault yeah and the fact that you can't
see that or maybe you do see it and you
don't care it's really annoying yeah
you're catching the channel that made i
should go into that you should talk
about yourself
made minecraft videos and their channel
started dying because they didn't really
change it up and it's just over like two
or three years so they had plenty of
time to change it up
um
and more often than not there is
there is a obvious factor at play that
went wrong yeah
whatever that might be
was that the end of the point yeah well
we're going to state the obvious point i
already said with yogscast you know like
they just didn't change their content
okay because the way you ended that was
like and then there was an obvious
decline you know uh
you ended that
like you ended that sentence in a
comment so obviously it's so obvious
it's so obvious that i don't need to
state it
like name a channel name a channel i'll
i'll i'll tell you the reason
i'm so knowledgeable about youtube ryan
higa right here yeah he just doesn't
upload anymore what do you mean he just
stopped uploading every every video that
ryan did outside of the podcast did well
yeah like when he did a you know when he
actually tried it did well like he just
wanted to become a twitch streamer
congratulations ryan you succeeded in
doing what you wanted no exactly that's
what i'm saying i still think he's a
successful youtuber he's like not
pulling the numbers of his peak but like
to me that that doesn't matter because
it's you like you're everyone will reach
a point where they've reached the peak i
mean i i even i think i've reached the
peak that i can reach making anime
content right now there is just like to
me there's just like a cap of like just
purely anime content and like it's
i've tried for years to break through
that cap but i just don't think the
audience is there at the moment for
every 100 000 youtube channels yeah
there is one that will get a a breakout
that does well and blows up yeah out of
those channels that blow up there's
maybe one in ten that understands what
they need to do to change their content
and to keep evolving to have an
everlasting like
presence on the platform you know people
like uh you know michael reeves had like
a few videos that blew up yeah he
understood what he needed to do i don't
know i i don't know maybe he did i don't
know if he did it could have been sheer
dumb luck
but he was making moves and he was
making the content and upgrading the
things in the places that needed to be
upgraded you know i thought maybe
michael reeves doesn't feel like he'd
blow up but i i when i watched michael
reeves he didn't the whole [ __ ] when
his whole branding was the laser pointer
in the eye guys yeah yeah yeah yeah um
that was how he started and uh he just
blew up from there and he kept riding
the wave and he kept doing what was
right you know because a lot of people
and more often than not the channels
that do die are ones that had massive
explosions and growth yeah that's the
what scares me actually because if you
have massive growth
something is going you've kind of hit
the nail on the head in so many ways and
you probably don't understand why yeah
because you this is just sheer luck to
you and the first instincts is to go
keep doing the same thing do that again
yeah because you know when you when you
first do it and you have uh steady
growth yeah i think all of us have had
pretty steady growth i'd say none of us
have had months we've blown up insane
amounts yeah um you you get you afford
the cushion to make the mistakes yeah
of uploading repetitive content
realizing that's not the way to do it
you get to slowly make all these
mistakes yeah
and it gives you kind of like a a very
nice cushion of i can make these
mistakes and then i can learn from them
it's it's like the buffer that you get
because to me the the biggest thing that
scares me when i see
like maybe an up-and-coming youtuber or
maybe like a new youtube make making
content on the platform is when they
have one or two videos that blow up it's
it and then it's it's a pattern i see
where you have one or two videos that
get millions and millions of views and
then the next video gets like 20k videos
yeah like i've seen that so many times
yes like like mr beast right mr beast uh
blew up on some weird [ __ ] videos
like yeah counting counting to a hundred
thousand yeah like insane ten thousand
iq yeah and then he just kept building
on it he never he never ever repeated
something for too long yeah you know he
he repeated it a little bit which is
fine you can do that i'm not saying
don't repeat ideas he deviated like oh
yeah you made like a derivative
you know so
logan paul every day bro for 10 hours
yeah right or 24 hours right so he took
what was successful about the one video
yeah sorry jake paul wow
fake youtube terrible
he took that he took the aspect that
people liked which is watching something
for an absurd amount of time or doing
something and then applying it to
something else and it worked and then he
realized okay now i'm getting all the
success how do i then what's what's kind
of the virality here what's what's
enticing people it's just the end and
insane absurd nature of what he's doing
so then he decided i'm going to spend a
[ __ ] ton of money which is like the next
best step if you can waste a ton of time
what goes hand in hand with wasting time
spending too much money yeah two sides
of the same coin like it's the same
thing yeah and it's genius yeah he he
was just the master of making content
that was so ridiculous that no one could
emulate it yeah no no one wanted no one
wanted to emulate i mean i mean what
watching mr beast right it's just it's
just like it's a masterclass in youtube
i'm just like i'm watching mr beast and
like every time he makes something new
or makes new moves or something it's
like you know you know when like you
feel like you you feel like that side
character in an anime that's just like
okay this is the genius character and
i'm just merely the side character in
his story that's what i feel like
watching mr beast side character that
has to commentate every movie
i can't believe he just did that move
what's that i'll explain it like when
when he just like [ __ ] opened a
burger chain i was just like you are
[ __ ] mad but that is like the most
genius movie yeah i could ever see
anyone doing because no one no one's
even close to his genius and like i
don't know like i i think part of it is
just experience because like mr beast
went so many years making so many
different types of content and then he
blew up like i think like seven years
into his youtube career so he just has a
lot of experience under his belt but
there is just a natural genius to some
of the stuff that he does that it's just
unmatched by every other content creator
right now yeah and and you know god
forbid there are so many channels out
there right now that are trying to do
something of similar taste to what mr
beast is i mean i think he's in varying
levels i think we'd be lying if like we
hadn't taken some kind of idea or a
concept from mr b onto our own channel
spending money are cool things yeah
exactly right that's why i'm many of my
titles there's money in it because yeah
it works yeah yeah yeah exactly i think
every youtuber has done at least one
video where they've tried to do
something similar to varying levels of
success i mean i mean you see you often
you see kind of you see content creators
like you see these type of content
creators come in the platform every so
often where they just like they're so
ahead of the game that they just like
completely revolutionize the content on
the platform like casey neistat i
remember when like every vlogger tried
to be casey neistat because he was just
when he first started making the vlogs
that he did which was just like taking
taking a day and instead of just making
like this handycam vlog but just
actually making it kind of like a short
film yeah and that was just like that
was revolutionary for the time and like
nobody could touch him for the longest
time because he had to be insane to do
what he was doing yeah he was like
guilty
four hours of sleep and he had like a
family and like this [ __ ] was insane
like the the amount of [ __ ] he was doing
in a day i felt exhausted watching and
he has like a factory full of cameras
yeah and then he went and then he went
home and edited it and i'm like i i i
would rather shoot myself yeah
obviously this looked insane it's not
dude just like daily vlogs it's just in
general totally not surprising you got
burnt out and quit doing yeah like
you know anyone have you ever seen the
film limitless yeah yeah uh like i feel
like i feel like if there's any real
life example of someone who's discovered
that drug it was casey neistat when he
first got like when he first started
blowing up man because my god like it's
it's like it's such an example of
someone who's just like
how are you finding this many hours in
the day man
you are using
of your brain yeah you've discovered the
limitless drug yeah oh that's insane i
just i mean so much respect to the dude
but like just jesus christ yeah he
really set the bar high
i get exhausted thinking about what he
was doing yeah like it's insane we don't
we don't even do a tenth of what he's
done
[Music]
yeah my god like
i've had like these past three months
have problems possibly been the most
busiest three months of my life and it's
still like it's nothing compared to what
whatever the [ __ ] that he went through
at his people for years for years as
well i guess he's also taking a [ __ ] let
alone just like
thinking about doing what he's doing
yeah i mean like i just i don't have
energy for that
jesus
like okay so like how long
how long did it take you doing work on
youtube before you realized man it's uh
it's it's [ __ ] tiring doing videos
like
because i feel like i feel like every
youtuber goes to the phase where
like youtube making videos at some point
was just easy it was just like i'm
getting i'm getting paid something
that's my hobby it's where you first
make a video and you're like i don't i
don't think i like this
i don't think i like this video
i think i hate this it's when you start
to become like really perfectionist
about your videos i feel cause like when
you're starting off you again you have
that honeymoon period of like everything
you make is like oh that's cool that's
fun let's do that yeah i enjoyed that
yeah let's go but then as you start to
make more content as you start to grow
and you start to realize oh i gotta like
up my quality in the content and not my
quality of the cameras or whatever
that's when you start to get a little
more self-reflective on your own content
right and you start to think oh
that video i made last week that i was
loving now that i look at it could have
done a lot better on that maybe maybe
this next video i'll do a lot better
yeah and i feel that's the point where
you start to be like oh okay now this is
like seriousness
this is like a job now yeah it's like
kind of not only is my rent and like my
living on the line for this for the
success of this video but also like just
my artistic integrity of making content
now yeah is kind of on the line and i i
don't like integrity
i mean you know not every youtuber can
say that the same thing
i feel like i don't i feel like i just
make stuff i like i don't know right but
you know but at the same time you'd be
lying if you said that you didn't care
about how your video looked or how oh no
of course not i i love making a good
video i mean so i feel in a lot of ways
like as much as you maybe don't want to
admit that is in a sense artistic
integrity like you want to make the best
you want to make the best [ __ ] you can
make yeah you want to make sure you're
proud of yeah you enjoy that that's
that's just been my philosophy and
that's why i've never like paid too much
attention to the algorithm and stuff
like that maybe maybe seeing what kind
of content is doing well or stuff like
that but at the end of the day i'd like
it sounds like such generic advice or
whatever but it's kind of true in a
sense where just good good content is
king at the end of the day there's some
there's some videos that will not
perform as well on the algorithm but
for the most part if you make good
content people are going to watch it and
then at every so often you get something
like diamond which just [ __ ] blows
your mind because you're just like okay
i don't understand that's the thing
right i just okay maybe maybe i'm wrong
maybe maybe my entire understanding of
this platform has just been warped but
that's the thing right at the end of the
day i think everyone is asking the
question what is good content
like what the [ __ ] does that even mean
right because like to some people that's
dumb man yeah to other people it's a gig
video like
we don't know what is good content at
the end i think dominant is i mean you
can't say it's bad it's very well
produced it's just like it's just so
absurd and the amount of views is so
absurd yeah so that's what's just kind
of crazy right i think it's just
insane
the amount of views this man brings in
yeah i mean i i could honestly yeah i
think that's the biggest thing because
he he makes well-produced content and
it's it's just like it's just not
correlational to like kind of like the
views that
it's like these videos are amazingly
produced but the story is just [ __ ]
bizarre like it's like a child
it's really strange because everything
else is amazing right like this these
videos are shot better than almost any
other youtube video like it's insane
yeah i don't know like i've always found
it fascinating like the kind of whole
question of like what is like a
successful video what is like a good
successful video right because like you
know if you're talking about like okay
is a good is good content one that has
quality yeah right i mean like how do
you explain the [ __ ] chunk chart
video that has 10 million views you know
that's that's like that's called quality
yeah i don't know what you're talking
about joey but like on on a traditional
sense it's not well it's like it's like
you know like report of the week right
you just write it's like in production
quality is terrible yeah it sucks
but it's like it's amazing because it's
what made youtube great
and i feel that's like a big question
that like a lot of people who are
starting off youtube ask right it's like
you know like they go up to the youtuber
who's been on the platform for a while
being like okay so you're telling me
that in order to be successful i need to
make good content
explain that what is good content good
content is anything that you know you've
taken the time to consider every aspect
of the content you've you consider audio
you consider visuals like you watch a
report of the week video yeah the audio
quality isn't professional but you're
like you can hear it it sounds good
enough it's not it's not unpleasant you
can watch it it's good enough you know
he doesn't try and egregiously clickbait
it he doesn't chase trends you know i
feel like bad content to me is someone
who is just chasing trends for the sake
of it yeah the clickbait is just
disgustingly egregious they're making x
thousands of dollars never considered to
upgrade equipment you know stuff like
that you know if you're if you're a
full-time youtuber
and you're using like a usb mic i'm just
like what bro they're like they're
literally a hundred bucks and the audio
quality difference is insane yeah yeah
there's no excuse in my mind uh other
than oh i don't want to look it's too
complicated it's not that difficult
but i normally notice that the people
who do trace chase trends have like have
like a set shelf life yeah yeah they'll
they will get massive amounts of views
for like one or two years at most or or
you'll go to their channel one video
will have a million views one will have
a hundred 100k yeah and it's like it's
like that's how you can tell like that's
a channel where you're like
probably not making the most consistent
stuff yeah yeah yeah or the your content
you're you're clearly just you know
appealing to a wider audience that
doesn't have so much care
about you you're only as worth as much
as your worst performing video
yeah like if you're
if a video that doesn't get in the
algorithm doesn't do well people still
show up and watch it yeah that's how you
can kind of tell
i guess that's your core thing yeah
that's that's like what you know the
people who really would turn up and
that's what if you can pull in
you know x amount of views that is like
a healthy amount on your worst
performing video that says a lot i think
yeah uh if you are pulling in a million
views then you pull in 50k i think
something's gone horribly wrong though
and you're clearly you're doing
something that's not healthy or
sustainable yeah and sure you can keep
tracing chen chasing chen but
youtubers who start to do questionable
things because they get so desperate for
these views they start doing these
horrible video ideas um you know like
actual like just click bait you know
some real egregious stuff you know it's
like where the prank channels you know
you can look at these clear examples
where they were chasing pranks so much
that it became to the point where it was
no longer approaching yeah well yeah
they they started they would do stuff
like
pranks in the hood where these like
white guys were just going like
slap oh i've seen them they were just
trying it was it was just like a try to
get shot challenge or something like
that right what the [ __ ] is this and
then they would also it got to the point
where every single prank channel was
paying actors and then there was like
kissing pregnant women prank and it's
just like this is just like what is this
like this is so beyond clickbait now
where you have to to get views you have
to go into such egregious territory you
know and with the family channels where
they would just
put their [ __ ]
here's my here's my child's uh vasectomy
for 10 million views you know it's like
what is this this is not this
oh yeah today my children are gonna
fight to see who's the strongest 10
million last one to survive gets burger
king i joke but some of these channels
were doing such egregious stuff to their
their children that you you may as well
have put that up for [ __ ] sake yeah
you know what i mean like
i feel like when you chase trends and
you're the kind of person who's willing
to put morals aside to get the views is
when you really see the worst side of
youtube come out yeah and i'm not saying
if you trace chens you're going to be
doing some horrible stuff on youtube but
it is it is a tasteful way of doing it
there is a there is an uncomfortable
uh similarity to the people who started
chase trends who so sort of starting to
get into the questionable area yeah and
that there's a kind of there's a
definitely a a spectrum yeah
distastefulness as i like yeah yeah and
you can tell when someone's on it yeah
no because like for me like when i think
what when i think about what kind of
content i want to make or what
what what good content is i just i just
think back to that like like i just
think back to that like seed in pokemon
or something where it's just like i
remember like the editor of shonen jump
in that series said like doesn't matter
what you make as long as it's
interesting like that that to me like
that to me is like what sticks out my
mind whenever whenever anyone thinks you
know whatever the algorithm is whatever
video you want to make just has to be
interesting to someone yeah
unfortunately and uh but we've seen the
kind of like toxic
content in traditional media right like
tabloids right it's like
you're you're ruining someone's life to
get content yeah you know it's uh
paparazzi yeah it's a thing as old as
time if someone wants it there's someone
and someone's consuming it someone's
gonna make it yeah whether it's good or
bad or not is another question entirely
you know like nobody respects tmz yeah
but tmz exists because it gets views you
know yeah yeah the same is on youtube
you know and these channels are gonna
exist because people are gonna watch
them naked yoga exists on youtube should
it i don't know but people are watching
it
what do you think of uh drama channels
what's what's because i i feel like this
that's that's a kind of word
i feel like there's such a fine line
with drama channels from being like
acceptable to just pure cancer right
it's it's it's such a i wonder who
you're talking
it's such a it's such a like fine line
to uh to tread right and i think i think
when it comes to drama channels there's
the right way to do it and there's the
wrong way i like scarce excuses i was
about to say i think scarce is a drama
channel done right because he merely
states the facts yeah that's it like
then there's there i feel there are too
many drama channels that think that
they're also commentary channels when i
feel those are two very different things
yeah like you could be a drama channel
that like scarce who just states the
facts like this is what happened i don't
want to hear their opinion yeah and then
there are people who are like here's the
drama here's why you should be on that
person's side like that's cancerous yeah
right like just just be like just say
what happened
just state the fact and let the audience
make up their own mind i don't think
there's anything wrong with that to be
honest i think that's why i like the
right opinion as well because at least
like he he does
he does put his opinion in it or like
whenever he's breaking down whatever
drama or whatever that's not the core of
his videos that's not the core of his
video right he's breaking down what's
happening and he he separates that from
his opinion it's it's it's like a clear
divide and that's that's kind of what i
like because you know he allows you to
make up your own mind but then he also
you know he also puts in his own opinion
as well his own perspective and i feel
like that's that's kind of the right way
to go about it and and you know
you know even even sometimes there's
might there might be drama channels that
do that but they're also just toxic
personalities as well right and again
like i feel it really does come down to
like the personality of the presenter as
well like if you if you
sell yourself as this kind of like
like you know starting a mob like talk
you know toxic kind of guy who then also
gives your opinion about a certain piece
of drama that
let's be real you're not [ __ ]
involved with yeah you just saw it and
you're like oh dude check check out this
fight that's happening right now let's
let's root for one person right that's
when it becomes toxic but if you're just
like here's what's happening you've
probably heard of it uh here are the
details
make up your own mind yeah you know it's
like i'm not involved i'm just the
messenger
do what do with it what you will then i
think i think
in a lot of ways
that's fine yeah but again it really
just depends on like how you present it
and how you present yourself yeah this
is why i can never be a drama channel
because i i would just like overthink it
so much that i probably wouldn't even
make the video right so much drama how
do you keep up with it exactly
very exhausting yeah like i like hot
like 99 of the time i just don't give a
[ __ ] honestly one thing that like we
we've we've talked about toxic anime
fandoms but i think in general
compared to like the other communities
and the other other things going on in
other place i think any tube is like
kind of like chill and drama free i mean
we've we've had like our drama but
compared to what we've seen elsewhere
it's been like pretty tame yeah that's
pretty sure now yeah it used to not be
that chill but i feel like it's really i
feel like even when it was not that
chill it was like still way more chill
than it was it was way more contained
yeah like it wasn't like the other
communities where like people from other
communities would hear about it but the
thing is with communities right and then
drama is that it it's you know as much
as people want to unless someone does
something really scandalous like really
[ __ ] and that that transcends beyond
the community and it's just so [ __ ]
that even like normal people like whoa
you know that's that's a rare
circumstance but other than that the
drama in the community is caused and
solely responsible is by like the
biggest creators in the community yeah
if the biggest creators are making drama
in a space then there's drama in that
space yeah you know what i mean like if
we're anime fans and we start doing
something that's really fun we better
watch ourselves then
it's true you know
yeah if there's if
we do something it's it's it's kind of
in the anime community right it's kind
of that would be considered not saying
that we're so big to dramatically but
like when you know the community
is kind of almost dictated at times by
like the biggest people in it oh yeah
yeah and uh that behavior is reflected
downward so if you if you get into [ __ ]
and you say a bunch of [ __ ] yeah the
community's gonna kind of mirror that
this episode is sponsored by honey we
all shop online we do and we've all seen
that promo code failed to taunt us at
the checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past thanks
honey is a free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart honey supports over 30 000 stores
online that can range from tech sites to
gaming products anything you can think
of now that is pretty poggers
imagine it you're shopping one of your
favorite sites i'm imagining when you
check out the honey button drops down
all you have to do is click apply
coupons
wait a few seconds searches for coupons
you can find for that site if honey
finds a working coupon is that it you'll
watch the prices drop that's it that's
it nothing else
what did you save money on joey well i
save money on pizza because pizza is
expensive as hell in japan just how much
did you save joey about like 15 20 bucks
which is a lot considering again like
pizza in japan is so so you just got a
normally priced pizza i got a normally
priced pizza when pizza is like a luxury
in this country thanks to honey so thank
you honey honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings 2 billion dollars that's not
a real amount of money that's one second
of jeff bezos
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast so you can get
honey for free at joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joining honey.com trash
taste links in the description below
thanks for honey for supporting this
podcast back to the episode circling way
back earlier on
okay about passion projects yeah you
know any any passionate projects you've
been working on recently i've done the
fake one um i guess i don't i kind of
don't want to talk about it yeah i
almost don't want it i could because
because like i talked about the fake
video and people were asking about me
about it for an entire year because like
here here's the thing when you're
working on a passion project yeah it
feels great you just you just want to
talk about it you want to get it out and
then you forget that you have to make it
as well
that's literally me with the oyster
video
people have been asking i've been
writing that [ __ ] for years now it's
like when is it when is it coming out
and i'm like don't [ __ ] rush the
passion okay
i probably recorded is one of my
favorite one of my favorite videos uh
the other day and it was just so fun and
it was
very fun everything about it was great i
i filmed uh it should be out by the time
this is uh airing hopefully yeah if not
i guess it's a surprise
i filmed a video i worked at a gay bar
oh yeah yeah yeah it was uh it was very
fun they were just so welcoming everyone
oh yeah
it was a great time i i almost forgot i
had cameras on me because i was having a
great time reacting and hanging out with
the boys like we were just words yeah
man they were just it was just so fun
and especially in japan you know because
uh people are
very closed off here yeah and it's very
much just having a guy be like hey
what's your dick size and i was like
whoa i'm glad you asked i'm like well
that's the way to break the ice that's
something you don't see in japan
especially right i haven't had this in
japan i haven't had this level of uh was
he a jojo fan
yes he was did he see an unsucked dick
it was after i sing i sang uh sort of
uh
so you could just go and sing uh sing
anime songs yeah with the boys hell yeah
that sounds amazing it was such a fun
bar so welcoming it was just great and
uh yeah i just had an amazing time it
was great and it's one of those videos
where i didn't really think much about
it before i filmed it but i was like
damn this is probably one of the most
fun videos i've ever filmed that's the
best feeling just had drinks with the
boys yeah literally yeah it's really
weird actually meeting anime fans here
in japan because you talk to some of
them and it's almost like it's even less
popular than it is outside of japan
right
because it's it's really weird because
sometimes you meet an anime fan and you
say you watch anime as well they get so
excited yeah and they're they're just
like i thought i was the only one what's
your favorite anime and what would you
like watching and
and it's it's so weird because it's
almost being transported back like 10
years ago yeah except it's it's here in
japan i think i think it's because you
know in japan you know they don't have a
massive uh
social climate you know it isn't you
know people aren't exactly the most
social to one another yeah yeah and
especially
yeah and i think having a solid
icebreaker like you like anime yeah you
know it makes any anyone comfortable who
if you if it doesn't matter who you are
if you both like anime you can talk
about something yeah yeah exactly i mean
like i feel like in japan where again
people aren't very socially outgoing
it's it's such a good icebreaker and a
very comfortable one yeah and i find
that especially when you're a foreigner
as well yeah people feel a lot more
comfortable talking to you because
they're like oh you like the same things
as me even though you have a different
place yeah and it definitely makes them
feel more comfortable i feel it's
especially as well because unlike in the
west where like the whole like anime
community and like otaku thing is more
of like community based thing even in
real life here in japan it's very much
like a lone wolf type of thing like i
feel like yeah like don't talk about it
like the true like like hardcore otaku's
here
i mean for one don't really go out on
social life
that won't be outside like you know
being like walking around being like i
like this thing do you like it like
they're not going to be like that
they're going to stick with like 2chan
right and yeah about their you know
passion there right obviously but you
know and i feel that's why like
especially in japan that's so much more
rare to come across yeah because for one
it's like oh
i didn't know about this whole other
side of the community because a lot of
these attackers in japan
don't really interact with other people
in that even within the same community
let alone you know across the [ __ ]
ocean because like you you hear in japan
and you you talk to a japanese person
and even if they're not an anime fan
they're like aware of like obviously
love a lot of anime because we're here
in japan but like you meet an actual
person who watches who watches anime and
it's like i'm transported back to like
the early periods of when i got into
anime because i've never seen someone's
face just i've never seen a japanese
person's face light up so much when you
say you watch jojo or when you say you
watch some other like some other anime
that's maybe not ava or one piece you
know because those are like those like
the two mainstream anime here that even
like non-anime fans watch and i i guess
like that's just not what i expected
when i moved to japan because i thought
i thought at least like i didn't know
because i'd only heard about you know
the otaku culture from
basically from third-hand accounts right
i'd never actually had experienced it
myself so i didn't know that anime fans
just are still
almost like underground here in some in
some senses right and that just kind of
like blew my mind yeah i mean i feel
maybe within like the past like say 10
20 years yeah like much like the west
right i feel it's become a little bit
more open and accepting and like you
know
you know like even in the west right
kids 10 20 years ago would get bullied
for watching anime now you get bullied
for not watching anything i feel in
japan it's kind of become the same thing
now except still at the end of the day
like the true like hardcore tacos are
still very much underground because i
think i think they're scared to come out
yeah but but i feel like you know you
said that they're underground but you
know like every time you watch a
documentary anything about japan and
otaku's you always saw the hardcore yeah
they'd be like
this is uh this is a uh tanaka he's
spent ten thousand dollars this year on
love life and it's like all right great
yeah but i think as well as as well
because like just the term otaku in
japan is just so much more than someone
who likes anime like yeah you have like
train or targets you have military or
tacos like
the types of fans and like hardcore fans
that you wouldn't really see outside of
japan i saw a hardcore america otaku
oh did you actually at my train station
and this guy was wearing a full uh what
is it bald eagles
what is it what's the american eagles
bald eagle shirt yeah uh a cowboy hat
like a ten like gallon one yeah he had
the pins of america on it
he's wearing
the bluest denim jeans i've ever seen
and he was wearing cowboy boots
and then he was just japanese and he was
wearing glasses and i was like this is
just so bizarre
at my training that's some drip right
yeah train station and he was doing the
like the [ __ ] handsome
handsome belt waiting for the the state
of the train to come and i was like
what the [ __ ]
that's so cool
i wanted to be like koni
i was just like this is so bizarre i was
like i want to know the background i was
like i want that guy to come on trash
taste like yeah i'm one of those dudes
i don't know it's just like because like
especially like you know every now and
then when you go to like a train station
in japan especially like uh like the
shinkansen like the bullet trains you
sometimes see you know some train or
tacos oh yeah those are oh yeah and
they're always taking pictures with
these like massive like bird watching
people in the uk though as well as big
big uh uh train spotting or whatever and
uh
yeah and you'll see them at the airport
yeah but like i always find like that
side of the otaku fan base to be just so
much more interesting i feel and maybe
it's because i know nothing about it but
also at the same time it's like it feels
so much more like mysterious because you
almost never see those kinds of people
interacting even within the same
community members because you also you
also see a lot more shows made about uh
attackers traditional attackers i guess
for the anime yeah because it's just
like oh look at this guy he spends 20
grand a month on some png you know yeah
it's a lot easier to get it yeah yeah
that's the thing right is that they want
to these film crews just want something
weird it's really hard to just make fun
of a guy who just likes trains
you know
like say anime and then the otaku anime
you know what i mean basically like if
if you see if he if you see your series
in like akihabara or something then it's
probably gonna be looked down upon by a
lot of people in japan because i
remember we uh we hang out with our
friend's uh girlfriend and she was like
a mad like amado turkey i remember
talking to her and she was like yeah i
got bullied in school for liking anime
i'm just like what
you're japanese what
how is this a thing
how yeah i think it's so common that
it's almost cool to not like it and do
something else right yeah yeah but i
don't know like the whole okay when when
someone all right this is this is
controversial
when someone is like severely into
something like a show you know
uh i was about to describe myself there
actually
i was like because you know you see
these you see these things where like
they make their whole life about
something
right this is me with jojo in it yeah
really yeah
yeah i saw something you know when i
remember watching this show one time and
this woman had like everything in her
life was barbie oh yeah yeah the one
living in l.a right the japanese woman
that's right yeah yeah i've seen it
everything she owned was bobby yeah and
i was like
is this like something that like can
happen to anyone or it's just something
that like
he he said he he ponders while his jojo
posters are in the background with the
jojo's statue
and the ten thousand dollar jojo wearing
his jojo suits listen i i love jojo but
i don't feel like because when i see
them talk about their show
i don't i don't feel like they talk
about it the way i feel about jojo you
know i think that's what every one of
those like obsessive collectors think
yeah but the way they talk to connor in
10 years yeah right
here's my jojo toilet this could be just
taken out of context and just click with
me talking about jojo i realized that
but like when i see them there's almost
like this like like this
obsession that feels
uh unhealthy
you could probably say that you could
probably accuse me of being the same
yeah but you know when i when i just i
just like the style and i like
decorating my office in a certain way
yeah outside of that none of my rooms
are jojo you know there's nothing else
are you talking about like when
someone's entire house it's like their
entire existence becomes
a collection of this thing right and i
just wonder i'm like is that something
that just happens to anyone or is that
or is it something that
maybe something's happened to you where
you you know you've had an experience or
maybe you've been raised in a certain
way
and that that makes you more receptive
to being obsessed with something i mean
what do you think i'm sure both sides
can happen but i think
psychologists in the chat can you let me
know i think at the end of the day it's
just about like how much do you like
this certain thing right yeah how much
are you willing to say i don't know a
part of me thinks there has to be
something where you have to be more
susceptible to addictive tendencies
um i also think there's just some people
where for whatever reason in their life
this this one thing
means so much to them personally maybe
it came along at the right time
it helped them through something but
like they are so personally attached to
this thing i'm not trying to bash you by
the way i just want to like actually
yeah i i i think i think that's the real
reason because i mean i i feel like a
lot of idol fans fall into that category
where right right where you know they
they want to support these idols because
they gave them something you know yeah
and i i i feel like that's more likely i
mean i'm sure there are a lot of people
who maybe have addictive tendencies as
well right yeah i guess because the the
whole thing that sucks about talking
with idol uh star specifically is that
you know here in japan
i mean there's just some stuff that's
[ __ ] like you know there was this one
i mean the idol industry in general yeah
yeah it's it's okay yeah there's so much
predatory [ __ ] that goes on in there
yeah and also i can't i don't know if
i've talked about this on trash taste
but this is one uh video on youtube done
by some abs i don't know which news
agency was it was some not not super
mainstream one they did like a
documentary with this british guy and
just goes to idle stuff yeah but not
normal idol stuff 13 year old idols
in japan
and uh men this is an uncomfortable
watch because it is like these dudes uh
go to these uh concerts with this 13
year old girl yeah and
she's dancing and stuff and uh the guy
goes around just ask these guys like hey
why do you like it and the the answers
they give are just really like
uncomfortable it's they don't say it
they don't say what you you know what
i'm thinking yeah but they don't really
give a good argument as to not that
there's actually there's a really good
documentary i saw i think it's on
netflix called tokyo idols yeah i've
seen that one
yeah but that one wasn't that bad
because that that i i really liked that
one because i felt like it wasn't an
insulting look into it yeah that was
like an actual like in depth but at the
same time i was trying to give a i would
say an unbiased look yeah yeah yeah i i
think that was just interesting yeah i i
watched it and like you watch it and you
don't you don't really wanna you don't
judge any of the people there yeah it's
just like to me it's just fascinating
yeah yeah right how someone ends up in
this situation where he you know they
spend thousands and thousands of yeah if
you want to give if you're a 40 year old
man and you want to give thousands of
dollars to a 20 year old woman that's
fine by me yeah i got no qualms about
that you know
you can do that that's your that's your
money you do what you want with it yeah
but like the one where it was like 13 i
was like come on yeah come on i mean i
haven't seen that video i should watch
it i'll send you a link later it's just
like oh my god dude and it's just like
it's so obvious what's going on and yeah
it's not a good look yeah this is one of
those things where it's like
some idol guy was like man these guys
are making so much money off these idols
child idols and it's like no no no no oh
my god
yeah i mean like even if you don't mean
it in that way that everyone's thinking
like it's it doesn't help it really is
not a good look i feel yeah but like
like especially living in japan i feel
like japan as a country more than like
any other country that i've seen or been
to like i i understand the word otaku
here because there are so many like
really obscure things that people just
get obsessed with yeah and like it's
it's it's there's no like definite
pattern in it but like we talk about
anime itakus but that's like the most
i'd say the most broad otaku there is in
japan
you meet people who are obsessed with
like really strange things that's almost
the most normal otaku yeah yeah it is
right yeah
because like you look at my strange
addiction you look at these
sand eating otakus
that's why it comes that's why it comes
to my mind because i feel like somebody
who eats the stuffing in their mattress
which is the real thing by the way i i
assume i assume tlc is 100 it's
rock-solid with their journalism and
this is yeah that was an accurate yeah
of course um i'm sure some of the stuff
on tlc has staged um some
probably most of it but yeah um you know
people who do the weird thing where they
like eat only fries yeah you know i feel
like that's that's got to be some sort
of
similarity to somebody who is obsessed
with uh a certain thing that dominates
their whole life i feel there's a big
difference between an obsession and an
addiction
you know whatever yeah i feel i feel
like
you know when you are
something is your identity you know it
is an addiction in some senses i think
like obsession addiction believes an
addiction to jojo
this just sounds like an invention
[Laughter]
that sounds like denial
day by day i don't think about jojo i
don't do anything to do with you really
you're you're advocating
i can i cannot watch jojo i don't i can
quit any time
listen i don't suck [ __ ] every day right
you're not looking for the next
right
this sounds like i mean yeah i don't
think about it most days okay i just i
love this style i love it in my room and
the suits are banging straight up fire
you can't deny okay yeah like even if
you don't like jojo those suits are fire
you know what i mean right yeah if the
suit looked like [ __ ] i wouldn't buy it
but it looks fire no it does i'm not i'm
not denying that i'm not denying that
now that being said
if i suddenly became uh just i
everything about my life was jojo i only
ever wore jojo things i wouldn't stop
talking about jojo yeah god i know what
you're going to say there was a phase in
my life where i i did only talk about
jojo that was a short period when i got
into it and i'm not proud of it
i've changed for the better intervention
god told me to stop i did i'm a changed
man
if only every jojo fan could be able
but also you know
at the same time i i think i'm like okay
i see these people who have these very
severe addictions or something and i
think okay maybe something has gone
wrong maybe it hasn't
but at the end of the day i don't really
care you you seem happy you're not
hurting anyone do what you want that's
that's how i ultimately that's what it
comes down to but i am just fascinated
of how one becomes addicted to something
like that severely you know what i mean
i'm not trying to bash on it i want to
make that clear i'm not trying to say oh
it's [ __ ] up or anything i just want
to know the process because it's just i
feel like because it's not a super
normal thing to do because it's not
something that happens every day to
everyone yeah what happens to make
someone super addicted to something i
just want to know
a stranger
yeah that's it's always about the
strange addiction not how it became my
strange addiction
i just think like especially in japan
it's part of the reason why japan is
such a gold mine for content right it's
just because kind of kind of like so
many people are so many are into so many
niche things because when you when you
make people have to uh become so goddamn
normal and so assimilated in society
anyone is dying to do anything different
yeah i think that's why we get so many
these niche and crazy there's so many
like niche bars and places which you
know some some you've been to some are
still out there probably like we
we're like to be famous to be found
because their entire childhood their
creativity's snuffed out yeah they don't
get to be creative sure so when they
become an adult and they they can make
money and they can live their life you
know finally it's that
epiphany they can they can take control
they can be different yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i i think that's part of like
the last part of the interesting thing
about living in japan is that you walk
down the street somewhere and you just
you find this random place you're like
what the who made this who yeah what
what like only in japan
a lot of things are only in japan living
here you just become to have such an
appreciation for people who
really do just don't give a [ __ ] and
love what they want here because my god
life is hard here if you don't conform
you don't do what everyone else is doing
yeah if you're the one sticking out yes
and so when i saw that that guy rocking
all his american attire i thought
[ __ ] man the balls on this man thank god
thank god he had a good pair of denim
jeans to contain those those giant bolts
you know he rocked up to a japanese
train station wearing that like that man
did not give a single [ __ ] what other
people thought oh yeah and it makes you
kind of happy because you're like this
man doesn't give a [ __ ] what anyone else
is my
it's funny because every like since
moving to japan and living in japan my
standard for what's become cool and
badass has just become so much so warped
compared to like when i was living when
i was living elsewhere because i
remember this i remember this one time
it was like
it was like a busy street in like
shinjuku right and uh and we were we
were all just like standing there
waiting for the lights to change and
then one guy
i i i'm walking right behind this one
guy and and uh he's walking towards his
massive crowd and like the lights are
still red doesn't even flinch doesn't
even stop just [ __ ] walks and jay and
jay walks and i'm just like
what a badass
like
the emotion that i and this is going to
be 100 accuracy you know at the end of
shawshank redemption when uh dufresne
finally breaks free yeah yeah that's how
it feels whenever a japanese man doesn't
conform yeah the son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] crawled through the mile
long pile of [ __ ] to do it
god damn i'm like he saw the red light
that says not walked and he it didn't he
didn't even phase him he said [ __ ] this
he said [ __ ] the system i'm just like
[ __ ] me man that's a badass and i'm just
like [ __ ] that my my status for badass
is so warped living here because like
you see that in england and i'm just
like oh it's just not a [ __ ] guy yeah
that's that's the key to living in japan
right is to live in japan and get all
the good things and not piss anyone off
yeah we're not saying to break the rules
in japan to be a badass don't do that
do whatever the [ __ ] you want like as
long as you're not hurting anyone and
you're not breaking any rules do what
you want yeah japan is such a depressing
place if you follow every single goddamn
my new rule yeah that doesn't need to be
followed yeah but that's the thing right
and i feel that's why japan is one of
those few countries that does birth some
of the the craziest looking and the
craziest acting and just like the most
like unique type of people because
you need to be like that in order to
[ __ ] feel like you're living
sometimes it's it's weird because it
seems like it's either one way or the
other it's such a it's such an extreme
right which is why like whenever i like
japan's famous for having like very low
crime rates right but for some reason
whenever you hear about a crime being
committed here it's the most it's a
[ __ ] crime the most [ __ ] up
demented [ __ ] i've like ever heard like
what the [ __ ] yeah it's like the other
day it happened right on the order queue
line yeah yeah who like went on and just
like stabbed 10 people because he was
like i just wanted to and i'm like she's
like the women are happy right yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's like i wanted to stab
happy women i'm like
what
what what like just just [ __ ] rub a
like hold up a corner shop or something
man like you never hear about someone
like holding up like a corner shop
there's just so many people who like
idolize uh japan in that way and i think
you know you have to be realistic about
it like i remember i saw i was with
chris and there was this uh he was on
facebook reading an article or something
yeah there was a post someone made on
facebook did you know japan has the
least amount of exams in the world and
it was like yeah but only for a specific
age group and then they [ __ ] them to
death with exams yeah they literally
ruin their life they don't get to do
anything other than exam and study like
it's like oh great great they get to
have one year where they get to run
around the fields and have fun and then
we [ __ ] them today
you know it's
you know the amount of pressure on
people to succeed in exams here i don't
know anyone who went to a [ __ ] cram
school in the uk
are you kidding me i don't even have
cram i'm sure there is one aren't aware
it is i don't know anyone else who went
to one
most people had a private tutor once a
week or something like that yeah and
even then it was like wow you have a
premium yeah
like education not good enough for you
five days of school not enough for you
huh it's just like i say that as i went
to saturdays
you know there's a lot of uh
harsh realities about japan that is
overlooked because we wanted to be this
rosy and beautiful place that is
i feel like we're looking where we're
lucky enough to
not have to be part of the japanese
system
we avoid the probably some of the worst
aspects of working in japan yeah you
know i think uh we work in japan in the
most comfortable way ever yeah and we're
working right now
i can just sit on my ivory tower looking
down on all these peasants and telling
them oh you should stop doing that
that's not good you should try working
from home
[Music]
well yeah i saw it wasn't there a new
hip thing with the young people well
wasn't there a thing where they wanted
to get people to come back into work
yeah and like a lot of workers like
please god no we want to keep
teleworking yeah yeah yeah we've
discovered the beauty of that is
teleworking yeah i mean i feel like it's
if anyone was going to love teleworking
it was going to be japan yeah oh yeah oh
my god it's like this is it's it's kind
of like mind-blowing that has taken this
long for them to adopt it honestly have
you been on a japanese zoom call
yeah unfortunately
so the summer right now am i in there
like please please i'm not i'm just like
please someone talk about the weather
just just just just talk about the
weather please like i know it's been
basic as [ __ ] i felt like i was waiting
for my turn to go on a game show or
something like everyone was just nervous
like no one said anything and then even
then it was like everyone would like
someone would say something i don't know
how i've been on zoom calls with like
americans and so much more chill yeah
obviously because you know whatever but
i remember there was
one call i had and there's five of us
and one person would say something and
they would just wait like 30 seconds
like process it and they would be like
and i'd be like
i'm like guys this is this isn't a
courtroom this is a [ __ ] zoom call
you know they would uh in america they
would publish some of the a lot of the
zoom court proceedings yeah and i said
that was there was more more jovial fun
going on in those than on these zoom
calls that i was having
i would just stand there it would be
sorry about jovial more more
uh you know even the judge would be like
how's the day going how good good anyway
yeah so this is far proceeding number
one you know anyway
i just thought i used the weirdest thing
that there was just like this weird
understanding that no one was allowed to
talk until everybody got on the zoom
call yeah like no
if they were because it's all about
procedure here
according to procedure then it's just
chaos and panic yeah i was just like
this is the this is the most
like unfun zoom call of my life
not that zoom chords were found not
another guy not the zoom calls are fine
but i didn't expect it to be like all
right i'm waiting for my hostage person
to tell my family about how much they're
gonna ask for ransom i'm waiting for the
godfather to enter the room
yeah it felt like something uh like
there was some kind of like like
spiritual ritual about to take place and
no one was like it was so strange
it was so strange i was like what is
this
anyway i think that's a good place to
wrap it up or a good episode what a good
fun episode i like how we talked about
uh toxic click baits but uh
as uh the the title you probably read
was complete click bait we don't hate
our fans
do the [ __ ] page you want to shout
out thinking bobby okay we'll do the
patreon show look at all the patrons
though amazing they they fell for the
clickbait but it's all right they still
support us because they're on our
patreon and if you don't care about our
clickbaity
ass then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com
yeah also follow us on twitter send us
some memes on the subreddit and if you
hate our face listen to us on spotify
subscribe subscribe subscribe and uh
that's been another episode of trash
taste we love our fans we love
offerings um jojo fans please stop
sucking dick um no don't stop
stop not all stop please sucking dick
not all dicks need to be stuck in the
world
like what
impossible
we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you